all right
morning morning everybody we're starting
the subcommittee for
um senate bill 277
by senator hennessey
and um
i have a few comments
and we distributed a few peeps pieces of
paper unfortunately we didn't get them i
didn't get them until last night
i wish we were sent them earlier so
everybody
could have a chance to look at them
one of them is the oplc draft
legislation from the director
and
another one is from
uh
bob clegg's organization right there
is a good bill
um
it allows us to hire more people
people we desperately need
um the way it goes around it it's
extending the state of emergency not
state of emergency but the emergency
authorization by another two year and
the committee i think the members of
committee felt that the emergency has
been
over for a little while so why extended
another two years to have a four year
emergency
so we've got to fix it in a different
way
and one of my questions
maybe the director can answer that since
all those licenses expired
five months ago four months ago like how
are they those people operating
if you would like
i'm sure we'll have more questions
and i'm good with them working i'm just
curious at this to the process
thank you representative um for the
record lindsey courtney executive
director oplc
what we did in january in order to avoid
the expiration of
the emergency licenses as you may recall
january looks different than
april does in 2022
is we converted via emergency rule
all of those licenses to temporary
licenses under existing statutory
authority which is in 310a so those
licenses actually don't expire until may
31st
and it was really intended to give the
legislature an opportunity to determine
what if anything to do with these
emergency licenses
okay thank you
anybody has any questions please
representative golly thank you mr chair
quick question
obviously if this is amended it's got to
go back to the senate for approval and
still got to go to the governor
and i'm not sure
whether or not this would be done by may
31st what would happen at that point
if it was not done by may 31st all of
those licenses would expire um
we do not have
statutory authority to
further extend those licenses
please
and
we
mr chair i don't believe we can go back
retroactively to reinstate those
licenses either
statutorily so that that puts us
in a quandary as to whether or not
knows this is in the pipeline and we can
really push this forward and
fast track it to get it done before may
31st i'm hoping that could be done if we
do something
yes please
and and then there was uh one other
question um that i had
as to
why
we continue the mail order pharmacy
license at no cost in this legislation
so
right um there were really only two or
three
instances in which
we opera we allowed
the pharmacies to operate a mail order
pharmacy
i'm not i don't take a position i i
personally think that one of the reasons
why we recommended converting these
licenses to permanent licenses was
the loss of revenue to the state
regarding the mail order pharmacies the
loss of revenue has not been significant
because it's only been a couple of
instances typically the mail order
pharmacies though the fee is two
thousand dollars
which is significant um
uh the twenty thousand or so twenty two
thousand people uh who did obtain an
emergency license uh did so without
costs of the state are without cost to
them um
so you know i i certainly would be
so mr chair if i may i i would like to
see the amendment removing the line that
says at no cost and if they're going to
be renewed that they pay the license fee
please which line
or i guess my question is do we even
need that section in if we're going to
charge the license fee can we just
strike out that section with the
emergency order yeah i think you could
we are currently charging a fee for new
temporary licenses that we're issuing
so mr chair
will of the committee i would uh
move that we strike out that whole
section from line 12 to
15.
um
yeah
okay so the the draft amendment by the
director right here
we all got it um that's the shorter page
so i don't know what happens to section
three
um
if the director can come and come back
yes
no actually there are
many licenses license tapes that are
multi-state licenses when
yep
no for nursing for example we issue
compact licenses which are considered
multi-state
no i i can appreciate that
um i think at representative you
probably um
you probably would need to change a
section three as well
well
i think section three
deals with the continuing issuing of
licenses so this bill really is intended
to do two things
one is to convert the existing emergency
allies or to extend the expiration date
of the existing emergency licenses to
and then to continue to authorize oplc
to issue emergency licenses
i will say that we are we have observed
a significant increase in the in the
amount of correspondence related to the
student nursing emergency licenses
which would
fall under section
three when it states that the office of
professional licensure certification
shall continue to offer and issue
emergency
licenses for health care workers and
those licenses would expire january 31st
of 2024. so i don't i don't think that
there would be a need to
convert those licenses because section 3
is talking about licenses issued in the
in the future whereas section one is
i i still would like to see
2024 change to 2023. um i don't think we
need to go
out to 2024 giving emergency licenses at
this point um if there is a need um we
can come back next year and extend it
out
i guess my question to the director is
if we keep section 3 in does that fiscal
note still stand
that's that's the issue i have the 680
i think giving folks until january 31st
2023 is
i i do think that the fiscal note would
change i i don't know off the top of my
head you know i wouldn't be able to do
that calculation right now but i think
certainly there would be a change uh to
the fiscal note if you were to change
there's a cost to the extent that we're
issuing licenses without a without a fee
so certainly you could make that
modification that we issue licenses with
a fee
um
additionally if you if we were to
convert the licenses and they would be
required to renew they would have to
meet all requirements which would
include paying the fee on renewal
but if you were to just extend out the
licenses
an additional two years
without
without receiving fees for those
licenses then yes that could potentially
be a loss because those people would not
have
sought potentially permanent licensure
and actually paid the fee but they
caught but the
but the fiscal impact really isn't
determinable because we don't know how
many of those would decline not to seek
permanent licensure as a result of
having the emergency license it's just
oh i'd prefer to see it go to 2023.
english thank you um please microphone
yeah thank you i would set the date to
when when can the next legislative
session realistically do it so that
we're not doing oh this is already
expired what are we doing and you know
wouldn't it be more into some halfway
through 2024 or something before
i mean halfway through 20 30 23 rather
than january 31st
when will they when will they be meeting
in
summer the senate the house the governor
signing it some work time
yeah i mean jane is in january kind of
unrealistic
i think there comes a point where we
have to
decide whether we're
truly in a still in a state of emergency
for this or we need to look at these
folks and say listen you either need to
get a new hampshire license
and determine whether or not you're
staying here
for that reason or
not
and that's do we we need to set a
deadline on that not just using an
emergency as i see your point but it
just in terms we're kind of scrambling
with this because the date was not
realistic
and that seems like january 31st is also
not
realistic right i mean they're not even
swearing people in for the next session
until then so i have a question then why
don't we convert section three just the
same to the regular licenses what's the
drawback
maybe
so section 3 would allow us to continue
to issue emergency licenses based on the
limited criteria for out-of-state
licensees that they have a license in
good standing it would also allow us to
continue to issue licenses to student
nurses
and medical fellows with respect to the
first category there was a bill
senate bill 330 that would have
allowed the office to issue licenses
permanent licenses based on that
criteria but obviously we there was
significant concern from certain
stakeholder groups so that bill was
amended
to essentially study the issue and i
think that
part of that study
legislative study committee could be
looking at
what do we do with these
emergency licenses
because certainly portability is an
issue in the state the way we fixed it
temporarily during the pandemic was to
allow us to issue these licenses but the
question is how do we pull that back
thank you and um
if we convert
most of them to permanent licenses when
is the next renewal is it yearly and
they have to qualify it depends on the
licensed profession so they all renew
most of them renew on a biennial basis
um nurses for example renew the month of
their birthday
um physicians though only renew in june
um june 30th is a common renewal date so
um
so if you were to convert them i think
that you would have to
potentially change the effective date to
just like the amendment recommends
the concern would be right if if the if
you were to convert them
and then
if the bill were in effect june 1st
and then all of a sudden 15 000
physicians have to renew
in a 15 day period that would be
problematic
um
we wouldn't be requi we wouldn't be
providing the required statutory notice
of 60 days
so
i might say you know rather than
one thing you could do on the proposed
amendment because of course when we
drafted this we were anticipating maybe
this would be an earlier bill
you could say converted to a permanent
license
you know
[Music]
um
or you could say for purposes of renewal
okay okay no this is fine the way it's
written for purposes of renewal the date
of conversion shall be deemed the date
of original issuance so they actually
wouldn't have to renew right away
i apologize representative for talking
this through
okay
would would senator clegg want to
testify
do you have any input on the summer
camps because we got the
what
thank you mr chairman
the the camps have a problem with
and it's the same problem i think that
everybody does that has a provision that
says you have to have a registered nurse
so one we're having a hard time finding
them
and two the ones that we have have come
here
and they've been working into temporary
licenses so we really need to have this
fixed before
june because our camping season and our
youth camps open in june
whatever you do if it if it helps us
we're going to work with the senate to
see if we can't get them to rush it
through to the governor's desk to get it
done
to us it's it's a matter of of life or
death if this doesn't go through we
can't open without registered nurses
so what's the timeline in your mind
what does it mean is it me
well we have right june 1st
if we if we're amended here we we don't
have a choice i don't know when your
next session is if you can get it on
your calendar right away then we can get
the senate to be nice if all their
regular stuff expires june 30th as she
just said just make it june 30th this is
may 31st i believe the temporary
extension
the sooner you get it on your calendar
then as soon as you get it passed we'll
go big in the senate to to get them to
push it and we'll speak to the
governor's office obviously it's it's
it's very important to everybody
nursing homes are having the same issue
so
anything we can do
to ease it up just for this year i'm
some kind of resolution permanent
resolution
overall requirements for licensing and
the places to call for licensed people
that we may not i mean
why do you need a registered nursing
nurse at a youth camp other than one for
people with special needs
i i don't disagree
and and i think that if we felt that
there was a need be nice to to be able
to hire some emts that that maybe have i
mean you know those are perfect
yeah
is that
part of the issue that's being addressed
in that study committee that we were
um
um thank you and
there was a note from
madam chair
with psychology something about
psychology
oh yes the um
these are some so we've already covered
with that the
the fact that psychology has some
requirements for permanent license
is something we're covering in in the
study of mental health licenses we just
approved yesterday
okay
so that's why there's so many temporary
and emergency licenses in psychology is
because the
requirements for a permanent license
are felt by many people to be excessive
okay thank you
so so
my inclination is to strike all the
dates out and either convert everybody
so that they get
through get to go through the renewal
process
whenever is applicable
so we don't have to come back to do this
again
the representative is one of the
possibilities to just leave it as it is
expiring january 1st 2024
31st 2024 just pass it as it is
and then
then we don't have to go to the senate
we don't you know just boom is that
wouldn't that accelerate things with no
changes no amendment but then we got to
deal with it next year again same
i would note that it also adds a 700 000
hit to the oplc in the fiscal note if we
leave it as is and i i can't support
that
well relative to the 60 million dollars
we just spent on lunches or whatever i
say that's a mere bag of hell that's a
difference
we got to discuss this bill
not your other bills
um
yeah so we may have difficulty passing
just suggesting that that would sort of
everybody seems concerned that we're
going to run out of time here and
i think we just discussed and we'll just
pass it as it is and it seems like the
governor would
care about kids a lot and rush it
through
in summer camps and everything else so i
think we have a good chance um as uh mr
clegg testified
i think representative golly has um
concerns
both i agree that the amendment we get
from oplc
is sufficient and i would also ask that
if we amend this that we remove the out
of state pharmacy section
with the at no cost
i think we've heard that
i don't think that's no longer needed
from oplc
so i think that would be if we're going
to do an amendment to remove that
section
12 to 15 you said right yeah okay
and anything we can do with the date in
section three
this is
thank you representative i my suggestion
would be to leave the date as january
31st 2024 even though i agree that it's
it's it's not a
great opportunity um or it's not in the
middle of a session but the reason for
that is i think this issue is going to
be fit squarely within the study
committee in sba 330. i think this is
one of the issues that we have to look
at as a state is
portability um
and that section three is really dealing
with portability so hopefully some
things will come out of that study
committee that will help inform
um you know the legislature as to what
changes need to occur so i would suggest
just
leaving it um
oh thank you one more question line 28
section 10 of this act will take effect
on the same date 20 um
section 10. and why is there another
date
do you know
yeah it's hard to find because it's
actually in senate bill 155 from last
year which has since been repealed um
prospectively pursuant to section 10. so
section 10 is essentially prospective
it prospectively repealed
the statute to on january 31st of 2022
this would change that prospective
repeal to january 31st of 2024
um
if that makes sense but you would have
to you have to pull up 155 from last
do we need this statement here line 28
itself
um which is section 10 shall take effect
on january 31st 2024
do we still need it
as part of this bill
i think you would need it because there
are other parts of
that build that 155 that are not
included
in this bill um
so i still think you would need
otherwise you would still have
authorization to continue to issue
emergency licenses indefinitely but all
of those licenses would expire january
31st of 2024 so on february 1st of 2024
we could issue a license but it would
expire the day prior
okay so this fixes something
in another bill kind of
this line fixes something in another
bill yes it eliminates the authority of
the office to issue those emergency
licenses yep
[Music]
any further comments so
well so it looks like this the plc draft
legislation the amendment
it's good
to go forward
[Music]
well once it does we're no longer fast
tracking it so then i guess you could
pick a date out of the air that you want
one that works
if all the new licenses are being issued
june 30th then
why not make this june 30th instead of
january 21st 31st or whatever
so in section one we're striking the
date
uh
uh and it's been replaced here by this
amendment
but section three and section
and line 28
i see still have that date january 31st
i guess
should the 2024 be changed
or something else is that the question
well representative goalie seemed to
think it was important that it be 2023
but january
31st doesn't seem to work in 2023 make
it june 30th 2023 and then it would at
yes
so
representative golly i think uh for
section 3 and line 28 at the end
and or the director
should we change it to
summer june of 2023
instead of january 31st of 24 both those
yeah yeah i believe so so
so section one will no longer have a
date
it will be replaced by the amendment and
then section
3's date will change to summer june of
2023 and then line 28 date will change
to the same summer june
june what
okay
right
june 30th of 23.
for everywhere there's 24 right now okay
can you repeat that again so i i got the
one for section one section one is the
amendment right i got that one but what
was the section two goes away um line 12
okay not section two but line line 12
through 15. and then
and then
line 24 and 25 the day changes to june
30th of 23
june okay and then line 28
we changed the date also to june 30th of
23.
okay
please
the current licenses or the need to
renew licenses and it would give all the
senate and the governor time to deal
okay are we
any any any comments from anybody
good
audience
any comments
yeah all good
um
i want to see if carol
when she comes back if she's got any
input
so
oh try to get it drafted maybe we'll
do we care that the fiscal note changes
because of our
adjustments
now
and then the question just um
procedural technical questions so
all of a sudden all these temporary
licenses get converted
to regular licenses will the people know
please representative
so how do you know notify them by email
you put it on the website
we typically don't mail viu and smail
the only board we're mailing for right
now is board of barbering because we
we don't have their email addresses
email for the remainder of the boards is
um
part of the demographic contact
information that they're required to
keep up to date with the board
um and our experience has been that when
we mail things out via snail mail
not only is it their significant cost to
that
um
it also requires a lot of time for staff
to stuff envelopes and the like
we're talking about 22 000
and we get a lot of return email at we
get a lot of return so we don't
typically mail out
um and in this case it's problematic
because 15 000
of
these individuals
were
mass license bulk licensed i if you will
pursuant to an emergency order for um
because they were new hampshire medicaid
enrolled providers practicing in boston
so the oplc
does not have a full um
we don't even have a full set of all of
their their contact information their
home contact information that's
contained by dhhs
follow-up yes please
yeah so i'm wondering if
you when you send out the emails if any
of them bounce
if you follow up on that and then try
the like regular mail because you know
things can happen you know their
internet provider can be having a
problem or whatever or they maybe they
just changed their email address and
forgot
well we send it out multiple times we
for traditional renewal notice we send
it out 60
60 days 15 days and then after
expiration
um it's incumbent upon the professional
to keep their information current and
that actually can subject them to
disciplinary action if they don't
so um
you know as you can imagine with 200 000
licensees and 18 license clerks it's
pretty it would be pretty difficult for
us to essentially micromanage people's
contact information which is why it's a
it's necessary that they do it
it becomes a problem when we have a
disciplinary action and they haven't
updated their contact information and we
need to do an investigation that's
really why
that technically is a requirement of
an ethical requirement
so
i asked you if when an email bounces you
maybe revert to the u.s mail and is your
answer no correct my answer is no we do
and did i also hear that you have people
that are licensed and you don't even
know their their residence you don't
even know their
address where they are we have
individuals who are issued an emergency
license pursuant to an emergency rule
they are new hampshire medicaid enrolled
providers meaning that dhhs has access
to all of their information
and we worked with our agency partner to
issue them those licenses and dhhs
facilitated that communication
okay so is your plan to move that data
into your database correct that would be
part of the plan if the legislature
would move forward with converting those
licenses but because if they were just
going to emergency for two years and
that would be the end of it then it kind
of like didn't matter correct and if you
may recall originally emergency
licensure was supposed to be for a
couple weeks right we didn't anticipate
this need for this transferring of all
this data so it has it has transformed
into something else such that now we
need to we need to plan to to migrate
good question um to the director can we
put something in here to help you
with that process
can you give me like 400 more people
no
i think i think from a legislative
standpoint um
uh we should be we should be upset but i
okay i mean
you've got a few minutes before we stand
it for amendment thank you thank you
representative um
thank you
microphone maybe i cannot hear
we're waiting on an amendment but
that'll come this afternoon or something
well it takes a while yeah
but
i really want to submit it
say it again do this again next monday
without schedule for next monday morning
if we have here i believe we might have
hearings monday um if we could meet at
nine o'clock to review the amendment and
pass it i mean it's not going to go
forward to the house until the
may 5th so we still have plenty of time
but if we could review it and get it
before the committee
next week for an exact then it would be
on its way yeah but
maybe we can get the draft today even i
don't know if we can get it by the end
of the day
no
i don't know
they send that email
i i think if we just put it in for
monday at 9 30.
give us plenty of time give them plenty
of time to get it together and make sure
it's correct
and then hopefully when we meet on
monday we have time to do some executing
and we can move this through um to get
it ready for the next house session on
may 5th
you're saying the subcommittee do a
subcommittee on the money okay yeah
we're here we're doing the full
yes 10 30 a.m
okay
okay so
but
yeah
but yeah i'll i'll ask to have it
drafted today and whenever we get it
we'll look at it and then it's a plan
i think that there might be another
subcommittee having
a subcom
but we can can we just i'll check with
the yeah the secretary yeah okay still
i can't hear you
sorry and here i was just thinking of us
so let me go over the changes once more
um
all right
yeah
so
section section one thank you thank you
we haven't started yet but yeah thank
you section one is
replaced by this draft amendment uh from
the op you'll see we got
right okay
section
the whole section two is gone from line
10 to line 15.
10 to 15 10 through 15
um
section three line the only change is
lines 24 and 25 the change
the date of january 31st 2024 changes to
agreed i guess yeah good
okay
and then and i have one more question uh
i don't see the director here
um
quite the only question i have is if we
remove
in removing section two if you go down
to line 26
it says emergency licensing procedures
and out-of-state pharmacies if we're
taking that out we may need to strike
out out-of-state pharmacies on that line
that's okay that's a question okay we
can um she's not here but that would be
a question i would ask i think we can
remove that
if two is gone does that
and then the last change is line
um 28 which engine into june june 30th
okay
yep
all right
no more input thank you
we're done with subcommittee we'll
continue next monday with the draft
good morning everyone welcome to edna
i'm opening the hearing on senate bill
274 and i call the prime sponsor senator
bradley
good morning
madam chair and
members of the committee glad to be back
here again
uh for the record jeff bradley from
wolfeboro and i'm pleased to be here to
be the sponsor of
senate bill 274 which passed the senate
earlier this year
um
just on a
general basis this is a bill about
competition it's a bill about fairness
and it's a bill about
transparency
unlike
um
past efforts
regarding project labor agreements this
bill only applies to state projects
there was a bill
a year ago that applied to state and
local projects
that any local projects has been
in new hampshire i'm told and you'll
hear uh testimony
on this fact
later this morning
that
um of people who work in the
construction industry are
not unionized
and so what a project labor agreement
does it requires if the state requires
it
for collective bargaining
for project labor agreement on wages on
benefits and so in essence it creates
favored treatment for the 10
of the workforce that in the
construction industry
is unionized the senate heard testimony
and i'm sure you'll hear the same
testimony that
project labor agreements
tend to drive up costs
and
um that's certainly something that we
should be concerned about as we're
trying to protect taxpayers
especially with a lot of new
infrastructure dollars in new hampshire
so let me just walk you briefly through
the bill the purpose statement is as i
articulated it's about fair competition
and it says on line 5 that the state
shall not include project labor
agreements as part of a competitive bid
process
so
if you look at line 18 it defines
government entity as the state
no other public entity its state of new
hampshire contracts
on line 22 it
defines what a project labor agreement
is
it's something that establishes the
terms and conditions of employment for a
specific construction project
and then it gets into the meat of the
bill starting on line 25
where it says no state
again government assisted project shall
include the following in its bid
specifications and then it continues on
to page two as to what
is not allowed in the bid requirement so
a prohibition
of for project labor agreement
is articulated on lines one through
seven
however
and i want to be really clear on this
what it doesn't do
if a
contractor wants to have a project labor
agreement that they have entered into
with a union
set of construction workers there is
nothing in this bill on a state contract
that would preclude it what it precludes
is the state mandating
project labor agreements
and you can see that
starting on page 2 line 9 and in
particular on line 17 where it says
you can voluntarily enter into a project
labor agreement
there is an exception
um
on line 27
if there are special circumstances and a
finding that is required
so that's the
nuts and bolts of the bill
i think it's a fairly simple bill
it's narrow in that it only applies to
the state of new hampshire construction
projects and i hope that this committee
will go forward with it thank you madam
chair
thank you senator are there any
questions representative marsh
thank you madam chairman thank you
senator for coming to us and presenting
this bill to us i have a question
particularly about the meaning of
government assisted on lines 20 and 21
and page 1 of the bill
in particular that refers to rsa 79e the
community revitalization revitalization
tax incentive
would i be correct that that would
include the economic opportunity zone in
manchester center around the notre dame
bridge where the advanced regenerative
manufacturing institute is currently
located making that project a
government-assisted project
i am not sure of the answer to that um
representative marsh i think it would be
best to ask um
other witnesses that will come behind me
that
follow up um i i believe that uh
we'll hear that later on um
we know that the city of manchester
recently received a five hundred
thousand dollar uh
five hundred thousand dollars from the
buildback better regional challenge
program to plan establishing a cluster
in that area and they're currently
competing for a 100 million dollar grant
in phase two of that
i happen to get the notice of funding uh
opportunity executive summary which i
would be glad to share and i note that
on page 21
grant that they have applied for it is
required that they get a detailed plan
on how the coalition will engage
community-based organizations and our
labor unions how the project will
incorporate strong labor standards and
economic benefits for local residents
including project labor agreements and
community benefit agreements that offer
wages at or above the prevailing rate
and included local higher provisions
my question relates to this project
which i had thought you were in favor of
uh is it your intention to make it less
likely that the the
city of manchester and their partners
will receive this grant or possibly
marsh you we cannot question intentions
oh you should ask is would the effect of
this bill be too okay with the effect
of that question madam chair
if you look on representative marsh on
line 18 government enemy means the state
i think you're referring to a city of
manchester project
uh thank you i think the question
relates upon the uh what the definition
of government assisted is which i asked
we asked you before i have one other
follow-up question madam chair
follow-up
i think we all can agree that the
department of transportation
is a part of the state of new hampshire
and the department of transportation uh
also competes for discretionary grants i
have in front of me
notice a funding opportunity for the
department of transportation's national
infrastructure investment the rebuilding
america infrastructure with
sustainability and equity grant program
and i note on that
on page 25 that again uh the
these grants require the use of project
labor agreements uh so uh
would this bill make it less likely that
the new hampshire department of
transportation would successfully
compete for such uh grants and make it
unable for the state to actually
build these projects i don't believe so
thank
you are there any other questions for
the senator
representative goalie
thank you madam chair thank you senator
for taking my question can you tell me
if the state of new hampshire has ever
had a pla agreement
my understanding is that
the state of new hampshire has never
entered into a pla but with all of the
infrastructure
money that's
floating around the state of new
hampshire and some of the surplus
dollars that we're allocating for
different projects
i think it's very important that
we
enact this legislation to protect
taxpayers as i think you would probably
be aware
according to information that i've seen
the job corps center in manchester
had more bidders after a project labor
agreement was
not adhered to and the cost came in at i
think it was about 15 percent less
because of
open competition i think that's what
we're trying to establish here
follow-up
and a follow-up is
with
all the money coming uh
in the transportation the 1.3 billion
from the federal government that's being
dispersed trillion that's being
dispersed
our
projects with
blas giving a higher
grade and a higher uh greater ability to
get some of those projects if they
i'm not aware of that again this only
applies to state contracts
and again
i would hope you would join me in the
intent of trying to make sure that
90 of the workforce in this state that
is
not part of a union has as much access
to the
ability to
actually do the work
and do it on time and hopefully under
budget and at less cost to taxpayers i
follow-up representative goalie i just
want to follow up on that comment it
are you saying that
the ten percent
will always overbid the 90
and they're not competitive
other witnesses
that will come after me that are in the
field in the construction field that can
offer that kind of evidence i think the
senate heard testimony that
project labor agreements generally cost
20 percent more
representative o'brien
thank you madam chair and thank you
senator for taking my question
in my high school years i went to don
bosco technical high school in boston
uh and then from there i went to
massachusetts maritime academy i feel at
don bosco they gave me college prep and
they also gave me a trade i feel that in
my life experience i done better with
the trade than i did with the college
education
in this particular bill by eliminating
uh the potential of unions which has
journeyman's and quite an exhaustive
process
to which
a person can come in join the union
learn that particular trade and become
an expert
you know true professional in that trade
by eliminating that 10 percent
are we doing the state
and perhaps even municipalities a
disservice
by having less than qualified labor in
working in this
for is it not most labor standards copy
or mirror the requirements that like a
trained journeyman
uh or a licensed uh plumber or something
like that would follow
so
let's go back to the bill
okay and if you look at
page 2
line 17
there is nothing that prohibits a
contractor
themselves from entering into a project
labor agreement if they choose to do so
there may be reasons that they would
want to voluntarily do that
all this bill does is say the state
should not enter into a project labor
agreement and i think given that we want
to have benefits for taxpayers
get projects that
will have more bidders and free and open
competition
that's appropriate to protect taxpayers
on the other hand the fact that a
contractor can enter into
a pla and it has nothing to do with the
counties or the state are the counties
or municipalities there's only the state
this is not undermining um
labor unions they'll still be able to
have project labor agreements but it has
to come
from the contractor
follow-up
well that's kind of what i'm kind of
talking about because by this particular
bill it would eliminate a labor
organization from participating to 10
percent per se no i don't think that's
the case sir
it's not don't yes at all i would just
say that
the state could not demand a project
labor agreement there is nothing that
would prohibit a
contract or a contractor working for the
state that voluntarily wanted to do that
because they felt it was the best thing
to enter into a pla from doing it but it
would say the state is not going to set
it as a precondition of getting that
contract so that's where
follow-up if i may
well in the beating bidding process is
that part of the free and open
competition currently does exist why do
we need this particular band-aid
well i think i've answered that question
already
okay
representative grota
thank you
senator bradley this is a little bit new
to me so
my question was very similar to how
represent representative o'brien's
question why is this bill needed i'm
sorry if you've answered that question
it went
through one ear and out the other so if
you could kindly repeat it i would
appreciate it very much because i we let
me just
we do not require these plas now is that
correct
so the best of my knowledge
there haven't been
state requirements for a pla that being
said what this would say is the state is
not going
in the future to require a pla because
of the reasons that i articulated that
90 of the workforce is non-union
plas generally are higher priced
that's why
follow-up follow-up representative thank
you
so if we're going to say that the
state's not going to require it
but the contractors can require it
if the contractor because remember the
contractors are are bidding on state
contracts is usually an rfp that's put
out we want to get as many bidders as
possible to get the best price and the
best quality that's generally how
state contracts are awarded
if a contractor themselves believes that
they can
put together the best bid using a
project labor agreement nothing in this
bill would preclude that if what it
doesn't allow is the state to demand as
a precondition
a project labor agreement so it's very
different if a contractor themselves
want to do it because they feel it's in
the best interest of winning the bid
in terms of price quality
ability to get work done on time they
can do that there's nothing that would
representative fellows did you have a
question
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
so i'm not really expert in this area
either
but i'm i know that
state the state
um
will
issue an rfp for a contract
that
uses all or partly federal money
so does federal money ever come with a
requirement to do this or
um something like a preference
for
um related to labor unions i mean that
could be a term and a condition of um a
federal
award of a grant my understanding is
that
there's been some discussion about
projects that are over 35 million
dollars would have to
um to conform with the federal bid
process that's my understanding but
you'd be better advised to ask that
so it i have a follow-up to that
follow-up
so
the other half of the question it it's
that's on one end so i'm going to look
at the other end also the state awards
money to municipalities for things like
you know
wastewater treatment and roads and stuff
they would not be impacted that would be
a municipal um
but i'm concerned that this bill might
do that
because
that the municipality would be
doing the contract
but it would involve some money from the
27 of the first page
it says no state government assisted
project which to me sounds like a
assistance of state money so let me just
say this if the committee wants to
clarify that
the intent of the bill is that it is
state contracts
and if the committee wants to clarify
that i would not
so
it doesn't strike me that the bill
the wording of the bill says that but is
your intent that this only applies to
state contracts using a hundred percent
state money
that was as the bill was brought to me
are there any other questions for the
rep for them for the senator
seeing them thank you very much okay
thank you madam chair you're welcome
yeah good morning
i thank you madam chair and members of
the committee
for the record my name is arnold davis
representing coast district 2. also as a
freshman rep this is the first time i
speak in front of a committee
so if i develop a stammer or facial
twitches i'm not having a stroke i'm
just a little nervous
uh i'm here before you today
to voice my opposition to senate bill
274 relative to governmental
construction contracts
senate bill 274 is a bill that is a
solution in search of a problem
not only that but if passed it is a
solution that could mean new hampshire
losing millions of dollars in federal
funding for infrastructure that our
state desperately needs to repair its
roads and bridges
supporters of senate bill 274 claim that
this bill will foster competition
and will ensure that taxpayers are
getting what they pay for
in reality this bill if it becomes law
will make a process of bidding on the
state construction projects less
competitive by favoring contractors that
are paying their workers less
there is nothing in the bill that
guarantees competition or even that new
hampshire workers
will be employed to work on the state
funded construction projects
what is most troubling about this bill
is the unintended consequences that will
result if
it becomes law right now new hampshire
is
in desperate need of federal
of funding to repair our infrastructure
and passing this bill into law could
result in our state not being selected
for federal infrastructure funding
awards
the bipartisan infrastructure law
that was passed by congress and signed
by the president lays out the criteria
that will be evaluated to choose who and
where federal infrastructure funding
will be awarded
in one of the elements for deciding
where this funding should go
uh labor standards and project labor
agreements on proposed infrastructure
projects i have serious concerns about
passing a bill that would right off the
bat diminish new hampshire's chances of
receiving badly needed federal funding
in the north country infrastructure
money is
probably needed more than anywhere else
in the state and the fact that the
sponsors did not take into consideration
that passing this bill could hurt our
chances at receiving this funding is
reason enough for us to oppose it but i
also believe we as legislators should be
supporting bills that seek
to solve problems that our state is
actually facing
and as new hampshire
has never had a pla
this bill seems only to add to
governmental red tape in further
regulation of the new hampshire
construction industry
where new hampshire has never mandated a
project labor agreement for a
state-funded
construction process in its history why
are we being asked to pass a bill that
would prohibit something that has never
happened
there are far more pressing issues that
need to be addressed by the legislature
passing senate bill 274 to benefit one
group of cons contractors
is not a good enough reason to
jeopardize millions of dollars in
federal funding for infrastructure or to
tie the hands of the state from using
an efficiency tool like a project labor
agreement in the future
we should not be in the process of
picking winners and loses
and that is what this bill will do
if it becomes law i respectfully ask you
to vote itl on this bill
and not to risk our chances of receiving
funding that
my community desperately needs thank you
thank you representative representative
schmidt
thank you madam chair
representative representative david
represented davis
you can't escape the hot seat that fast
man no not on your first shot
yeah
i'm not going to be answering questions
i believe there's people here far more
qualified than i am if that's okay
yeah absolutely my apologies oh fine
thank you representative schmidt will
hopefully you'll be able to ask your
question to the next person who
testifies
well representative davis the fact is
you've read us a statement have you
provided that to the committee or are
you willing to do so
you read us a statement
clearly a prepared statement are you
willing to provide that to the committee
yes okay very good that's my question
okay
all right
yep
gala
thank you madam chair members of the
committee
thank you for allowing me to speak today
for the record my name is richard gulla
and i am president of the state
employees association of new hampshire
we represent nearly 11 000 members here
in the state
i'm here in opposition to bill 274
to be blunt and direct we do not need or
want extra government red tape this
isn't the new hampshire way
we should always work to get as much of
our federal tax tax dollars back we want
to build bridges
fix problems and support bipartisan
infrastructure projects this bill will
not bring a single extra penny to our
state coffers
as president of the sea trust me when i
say our state faces rampant vacancies
for example the new hampshire department
of employment security has over 700
vacant job listings
for skilled workers in construction it's
been difficult to find workers because
this economy workers can choose to be
very selective
workers want good paying jobs with
benefits and protections
let's kill this bill and increase the
chances of more federal dollars
returning to the granite state
thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions
representative o'brien
thank you mr gullah are you okay to take
some questions
uh thank you uh
mr gold for taking my question um we
heard in this house a similar bill
kind of similar in a way
that
what has stopped any state funding into
a rail project something near and dear
to me from the commuter rail into new
hampshire that affects the
d.o.t workers that you may represent
and now i'm looking at this particular
bill and it seems like new hampshire
can't see past his nose the benefits of
true infrastructure and revitalization
into this community to how much it can
help the state raise money and try to
help to alleviate
some of the burden with the taxpayers
uh so therefore
uh
i don't know this is kind of a loaded
question but
is is this kind of like an anti-worker
type of a situation that we see out here
by some members of this legislature to
against the state from actually growing
and thriving representative please don't
speak of other representatives intent
thank you and i apologize madam chair
thank you uh it's just that that it was
just a more than casual observation
excuse me
uh but i'll leave it at that if you want
to impine on what i had to say
it certainly feels that way
are there any other members that have
any other questions
thank you madam chairman for the record
my name's gary abbott i'm the executive
vice president of the associated general
contractors of new hampshire
i have distributed a position paper
along with the history of
government mandated labor agreements in
public construction
white paper
from our national organization
so you can have that information to make
sure that you completely understand what
we're talking about as far as labor
agreements
i think jeb bradley did a great job in
his testimony
i look at this bill we are so in support
of this legislation
as it does one thing it protects new
hampshire contractors
whether it's union or open shop
when these pla agreements come under the
federal government that has recently
been talked about
those are federally
controlled projects
they're administrated by say the army or
the national guard
those are administered by those federal
governments if they require plas they
pretty much rule out new hampshire
contractors from doing the work
this bill is a protection bill of new
hampshire contractors
and i plead with the committee that's
what this bill is about this bill isn't
about separating union
from open shop
i represent some union firms as well as
open shop firms
and what we're trying to do is preserve
the free marketplace in new hampshire
we're trying to maintain that the
companies that work and live here
are maintained
in the future
this project this bill limits it
to
state projects now i know there's some
language in here that needs to be
changed
in order to make sure it's very clear
i know the language that was used in the
buy america steel bill that you heard
had language that said state
administered projects that may be better
language
used in this bill i'm just throwing that
out there as one who's looked at a
number of these bills
i think the intent was to move away from
municipal projects which have you a
number of people have raised those
questions
i this bill
just says and it and it says this other
states have adopted similar bills more
than 20 other states are adopting bills
like this
and i believe it's a protection of the
construction industry
in the sense that the government
shouldn't mandate any put conditions on
a project
that limit
the scope of who can bid on the projects
based on labor issues
that's really what this bill is about
so i would ask that the committee
support this bill
i think it
it goes a long way in doing open and
fair competition in new hampshire
i think you will find that other states
are moving in this direction because if
a pla was put on a state project most
likely we'll get out of state
contractors that will be doing the work
and some are okay with that but as far
as the construction industry we're
putting in place something that has been
a common practice the practice has been
and we have not had plas to continue
that
no one has given me a good reason so far
i don't think it'll stop
the money
it doesn't matter about the state
authorizing us i have not seen that
condition
but i think if you were to change some
language to state administered projects
it would be very clear
uh that you would get rid of some of
this state assisted which kind of opens
up the gray area but that's my
recommendation
and uh
i appreciate the time today to testify
before you but this is a bill in which
it looks ahead that these things may
come to new hampshire and it sets a
policy
thank you very much are you willing to
take questions i i am
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
good morning mr abbott so
if you recall because i know you've been
in this uh business for a long time
the
state
legislature uh reroofed this very
building
uh about
15 years ago
and
there were a lot of problems with that
process because
without getting into the details
so
we wound up
with a lot of difficulties in getting
the project completed and
i'm sure you recall that so is this bill
as it's currently
or even with your amended version uh is
this bill
um
likely to put us in a situation that is
favorable or unfavorable in terms of our
past experience
um with
construction projects but would it would
make no changes to what's currently
in the regulations but
you have to understand construction
we're not talking about
qualifications and pre-qualifications
that are required like if you go to work
for dot
you have to be pre-qualified to do the
type of work if you're an asphalt they
have to pre-approve you to do that work
you just can't come in and not be
skilled at that work so there are
things and protections under the current
laws
that help the state with making sure
that they get qualified contractors this
in no way does that this is about
the preference of a contractor whether
he wants to enter into a legal labor
agreement or not is his option
but the state can't mandate it to
eliminate 90 of the marketplace that
really is what about this this is really
what this bill is about it's not about
the
the qualifications and the other
requirements that are currently in place
uh this doesn't remove any of those this
has to do
with labor agreements
and so i just want to
make sure you completely understand
that's why i put the white paper in
front of you that you can kind of
understand the entire process follow up
madame peer
representatives so there there's been a
reference to the fact that some 20 other
states
are currently uh you know involved with
legislation of this sort do we have any
idea whether any of these
other states have experience
with the impact
of this type of legislation in terms of
how well that works
and actually
you know benefiting the contractors and
the state and the people thereby
or is this all
brand new legislation across the board
no i more than 20 states have had it in
place for i know at least more than two
years and have not heard any
uh negative responses to having that in
place in those states thank you
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking the questions
so
my understanding is and
if you could just confirm that the state
of new hampshire has never required a
pla in any of his contracts
not that i'm aware of
only the federal project of the
the manchester uh project
in which that went to court
and then
the project labor agreement was moved
for the job corps center so it's just
something that has highlighted this
issue for new hampshire contractors that
went through that process we don't want
that process to happen for uh
state-funded projects
follow-up
and you also stated that there are some
federal contracts out there that require
plas or there may be money tied to
a pla for the state of new hampshire to
receive
or a requirement maybe a pla requirement
may move you up on the list on whether
or not the state receives money funding
or granting
is that correct
um
i don't know of any
state money that has required that the
state
administer a pla project
the reference to the federal government
president biden did an executive order
in february was an executive order on
federal projects over 35 million but
that's not money that comes to the state
it's administered by those federal
agencies
and
it's it's problematic for new hampshire
but we don't get very many 35 million
plus projects
for federal projects in the state of new
hampshire those would be things like the
courthouse and the others that are
already built so
i hope that clarifies here
we we are not aware of any requirement
that has come down that has a state
but in the
earlier scenario i put out there is a
lot of money
that is set aside
ready to come here to new hampshire for
projects
i know specifically in manchester we
have money that we are bidding on
for projects that we sent in and
submitted to for the federal government
to receive funding
and those projects
may have a pla in them and when we bid
them out in manchester and my
understanding is this could affect that
money as it comes through um
so as a requirement does that not affect
this
legislation would affect those projects
well i think if you change it to what i
talked about earlier to state
administered projects
if that federal money comes as a grant
from the feds to the town
question thank you
uh mr abbott if we don't
if the state doesn't require it now i
guess i'm struggling as to why we need
this bill because if it doesn't change
anything and we don't require it now why
well i think it's a clear policy for the
state to make for all state agencies as
far as when this question comes up
otherwise we'll be back here when the
first one starts and i think it's a good
policy
so as a second term state representative
i can tell you we get a lot of bills
so
maybe it's become my personal
mission
but i think we should only we should
really serious look at bills that help
granite staters and the state needs
and if we we're setting a policy that we
that already exist because we don't
mandate this
so i don't understand why
you're just putting a lock on
on another lock on a door correct
um
i look at it like i started out in my
testimony is
you're putting in place a protection for
thank you very much thank you
representative o'brien
ah thank you mr abbott for taking my
question you said for protection of new
hampshire businesses uh perhaps as you
know i come from the firefighting ranks
and uh when i was in the committee of
transportation we came up with license
plate for firefighters and i says uh
well what would guarantee a firefighter
how would you know and said perhaps
maybe having the qualification in
education such as firefighter two and i
come to find out in the state that you
can call yourself a firefighter yet not
really meet the same qualifications that
i had to meet within the city of nashua
so therefore removing the safety power
of union involvement which has
very high standards of method of
operations and training and everything
else such as you mentioned even in the
field of asphalt to make sure that
somebody that works for the d.o.t is
certified to lay down the asphalt are we
not perhaps with this bill removing a
potential safety bar of guaranteeing
construction projects within the state
we are not
the state of new hampshire has put in
places regulations that require like 10
hour osha classes for construction as a
mandatory for workers there are other
requirements that are already in place
that
put in place for whether you work for a
union firm or an open shop firm and
there are requirements within the
industry regarding different
fields so i don't believe it has
anything to lowering the bar of any kind
represent
representative goalie
thank you manager i just have to follow
up real brief on a statement you made
about trying to protect new hampshire
companies and workers are you telling me
those that are
labor organizations are not new
hampshire workers or companies
no
i guess what i want to clarify is
i'm going to put it this way i represent
both union and open shop
and they can compete currently
within the new hampshire marketplace
they compete on similar jobs
but most of the contractors who have
labor agreements that have chosen to
have labor agreements have them for
individual trades their whole company in
most cases are not union firms
they are union signatory on a project
and a project basis and signatory to
certain craft
even those that i i'm classifying as
union do that on occasion
that is their choice and i think that is
what we're trying to protect that is
their choice
not to have the state
mandate that through a contract forcing
all the other contractors who don't want
to do that do that but i i'm i'm saying
it protects the marketplace that we have
that seems to be functioning fine
we don't have really complaints and this
really is to put in place what we've had
for a standard over all these years
thank you very much are there any other
ques
representative schuett
thank you madam chair thank you mr
abbott for taking my question
um
the fact that
several many new hampshire contractors
don't have large unionized workforces is
it not partly because
excuse me
of the practice of designating some of
their employees
as subcontractors rather than as
employees
i think you will find on most
contracting projects there are
subcontractors
and what the
and
i i guess i'm not really following your
question because i think that's a
standard practice that if you build a
building you're going to have electrical
contractors you're going to have
plumbing contractors you're going to
have many different fields
the project labor agreement would be for
the entire project and could have
thank you very much are there any
representative fellows
so i thank you um so i thought i
understood but maybe i don't understand
anymore because
you know i know that that electrical
workers
you know have a union and and
you know
those
contractors i think we're talking about
the big contractors that that
subcontract most of their work
so those big contractors
which i think are what you represent
they don't they don't actually do they
actually have a contractors gen
i don't even know what to call them are
those the general contractors
or
yeah there's a general contractor who
usually bids on the project
and he gets quotes from subcontractors
to do various portions
the general contractor may do portions
of the work themselves
so
the the agreement the contract is signed
with the state agency
after they bid in there the low bidder
and they go through the executive
council process
they're the they're the one responsible
for the job
follow-up
so
now i'm wondering if this bill even
if somebody bids on a prod project it's
that big general i don't know if general
contractor is the correct term so
general contractor i mean it's not the
electricians that are bidding on it it's
the general contractor and and i'm think
that i think that you're saying that
that general contractors are
not
if if you put a project labor agreement
on the project
the project labor agreement usually
requires everyone on that project to
follow those
individual rules that are placed in by
the agency
so it would apply to everyone on the job
right now you're absolutely right
some companies the plumber may be
unionized they or they may not be
but the contractor right now
selects those subcontractors
based on their qualifications are they
available
workforce can they do it in time
those things are all handled by the
general contractor but it's the general
contractor who signs the agreement with
the state and puts up the bond and every
all the insurances to to complete the
project
thank you thank you very much are there
any further questions
good morning i'm margaret burns
executive director of the new hampshire
municipal it happens all the time the
worst one i've ever heard is biernez so
brian's i can handle yes it just burns
her brines
[Laughter]
um good morning again i'm margaret burns
with the new hampshire municipal
association and we are opposed to senate
bill 274 on a very narrow basis clearly
the intent of the legislation based on
the prime sponsors testimony and
testimony that has come before me is to
apply this policy to state projects not
to municipal projects and in fact in the
senate the bill was amended to add some
language to the definition of
governmental entity on line 18 but it
does not apply to political subdivisions
however our concern remains with the
definition of government assisted in
lines
20-21 which does refer to any project
that receives a tax exemption tax
abatement or tax credit under rsa 72
section 80 through 83 rsa 79-e or rsa
162-n
specifically rsa 7280 and 79e are local
options for different types of local
projects as representative marsh and i
believe representative goalie have
already referenced
79e is the community revitalization tax
relief incentive program and rsa 7280
is the commercial and industrial
construction exemption and both of these
are local options so they would only be
local projects
my concern therefore is not only that
this bill could be applied to local
projects but that it also creates some
internal conflict in the statute does
the statute apply to local projects or
does it not and i think that's the issue
raised by keeping the
definition of government assisted
project as is to be clear nhma has no
position on whether or not
municipalities should enter into project
labor agreements our opposition is
simply based on the fact that
municipalities should be able to make
these policy decisions for themselves
about their own local projects um and
for that reason we are opposed to the
bill as written
i'm happy to take any questions if i can
thank you very much representative marsh
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question could you kindly
answer my question about the project in
manchester where they're currently
applying for 100 million dollars uh
which would include the advanced
manufacturing regenerative institute
i believe the project fell under rsa
chapter 79e that you referenced and so
under the language of this statute it or
under the language of this bill it would
fall under a government assisted project
so i believe it would fall under the
parameters of this legislation
thank you
thank you very much are there any
thank you chairman
um
bailey
i've heard we've heard from several
witnesses including you that this is a
problem because it binds the hands in
your case of the municipal people below
us
but
isn't it also a problem that we are
being bound by the federal government
above us
i mean shouldn't it shouldn't it be like
we should have these
our position would be no not only should
we not have this bill at all levels we
should not have legislation that binds
the hands of municipalities either way
to be clear in the past nhma has also
opposed legislation to require the
payment of prevailing wages in local
construction projects because we believe
that municipalities should make those
local decisions at the local level
it's hawkinson
i shouldn't be allowed to read this
as long as you consistently blister
everybody
consistently without doubt
thank you and you got my name correct
which is great it doesn't happen very
often
and i'm a first-timer as well so i
apologize for reading but uh i will be
doing that this morning
um good morning chair and the remaining
members of the house executive
departments and administrative committee
you can just you could just lower it
down to a little bit that would help and
that goes for everybody you kind of have
to eat the microphone for the folks on
youtube to be able to hear any better
it's awesome all right we'll try it
again so good morning everyone there we
go
my name is kim hokinson i live in nashua
new hampshire i am a 16-year member of
the carpenters union
and i am here as the northern new
england regional manager so i cover
vermont maine and new hampshire
i represent locals 349 and 352
of the north atlantic states regional
council of carpenters very long name
i am proud to be here on behalf of our
union members more than 2
400 in new hampshire
and i'm here to speak in opposition of
sb 274.
first our union supports plas because
they benefit everyone on the
construction site from the developers to
the contractors to the workers and to
the taxpayers
our public work projects like you
suggested
by this bill
all contractors union and non-union are
invited to bid
non-union contractors can be found on
pla projects pla's simply create a level
playing field
for all contractors because bids must
pay the same labor costs
this means the winning bidder
must demonstrate cost savings that truly
add value rather than simply paying
their workers less
secondly plas create jobs that provide
families sustaining wages training and
safe working conditions
sadly today rampant wage theft and
misclassification of workers in our
industry have driven down wages and
benefits as a result
a recent study has shown that more than
40 percent of construction workers 40
percent
nationwide must rely on some
some
sort of public assistance 40 percent
rely on public assistance
by using plas we know that the workers
on the job are paid fairly and they have
access to industry leading training like
the training that we can provide
at the carpenters training center in
manchester
this in turn benefits not only the
workers but also the state taxpayers
finally plas benefit contractors and
business owners
because they know that they have a level
playing field when they're going to bid
a job and they are successful that they
know that they have access to these
well-trained safe reliable workforce to
ensure that the projects are built on
time and on budget like we've heard
thank you for the opportunity to speak
and i urge you
to vote against sb 274. thank you
thank you very much you're willing to
take some questions if there are any
i'll give it a shot
thank you representative schmidt
thank you ma'am chair
you appear to be reading from a prepared
document have you provided that to the
committee or are you willing to do so
absolutely willing to do so i have not
yet
thank you
thank you very much are there any
further questions
thank you madam chair um
miss hoganson
would it be fair to say that
the workers that would work for these
i would say that's fair to say yes thank
you
thank you very much
thank you
thank you madam chair members of the
committee
i i rise uh to speak against this bill
as someone who's been in the contracting
business since i was 15
i can tell you that one it's not
necessary
and two all it does is encourages the
cheaters to find more loopholes
in all my years in the in the business
and by the way i'm 68
um it's been a long time i can tell you
that when when you decide that you're
not going to have any kind of a pla on a
big job
all you get
is the people who aren't paying workers
comp
are aren't paying their people the going
rate
i was on a job recently where i noticed
some of the roofers weren't eating lunch
i needed an interpreter to ask him why
didn't have his green card so they were
paying him seven dollars an hour
i've also been on jobs where they do
have their green card but they're so
afraid to say anything
and you find out they're not getting the
35 an hour that the rest of the guys are
getting to do that roof
and and what did we do
on my job i threw them out
not the guys that didn't have green
cards but the contractor because that's
not the way we do things we we require
that you pay your people
that anybody who's working there has to
be legitimate
and that nobody's abused we right now
have jobs going on in the state of new
hampshire large jobs paid for with
taxpayer money
where the contractors come from either
vermont or maine where the workers comp
is cheaper
they don't follow our rules here which
says you can only work three days here
before you have to have a new hampshire
workers comp they just keep saying oh
well i left and i came back
because their rates are so much cheaper
than ours so basically the idea that
we're going to save some of the new
hampshire contractors is a fallacy
we're not saving anybody because right
now we're allowing the abuse
and it's every single day
as i said we
in our company pay workers comp we
follow the labor laws
and and we have safety requirements and
everybody is our employee
you're right when somebody asks the
question how easy is it to make
everybody a subcontractor it's very easy
all you'd say to them is here's what you
get
and you know the worst part about that
is those guys don't know enough to save
enough money to pay their taxes that
they owe so at the end of the year
they're looking for their unemployment
tax and everything else they didn't make
any money
in fact on one case where i tried to
help somebody when they finally paid
their taxes and everything else that the
state came after them for
they actually made five dollars and 75
cents an hour
not even minimum wage but what they were
offered looked really good
until they got caught
so i'd ask you to not bother passing
this bill it's not necessary
and and to say that a state can't have a
project labor agreement it just says
here's what you have to follow here's
the rules
everybody has to be paid right they have
to have their workers comp
you have to have their fighter food or
suitor all that all that stuff has to
come out
and you can't make them
a subcontractor because it's cheaper
as i said i've been doing this a long
time and probably one of the few people
in this room who have actually run very
large jobs
and had both union and non-union people
working side by side
but on my jobs everybody's paid the same
so the only arguments we ever got into
is who was the better craftsman
and i appreciated that because that
meant that everybody was trying to outdo
the other to be even better
to take away the pla's on my right to
have a pla
is to take away the idea that
everybody's going to have a fair
opportunity and every contractor can
actually bid
knowing that they're not going to be
outbid by the guy who cheats on a
regular basis thank you madam chair i'll
take any questions
it's not my first time representative
goalie
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking the questions
being around long enough
we hear
plas
could be increased costs on a project up
to 15 percent somewhere in that range
in being around in construction business
long enough does
a low bid
always mean
a quality project quality
completed project
if somebody's 15 less
typically what happened is they've
they've forgotten something or they have
a plan on not doing something and if you
want to talk about asphalt instead of
three inches you're going to get two and
a half
um there's all kinds of ways of cheating
the system
and and cheap it's not always the best
bid
representative fought now
thank you madam chair um just for the
record could you
state what your name is and either what
company
you represent my name is robert clegg
i live in hudson new hampshire
and i'm actually here speaking for
myself and some of the companies that
i'm a partner in
thank you
representative grota
mr clegg
this bill doesn't require plas it just
leaves that up to
the bidding process so i'm not sure
your position is that
they shouldn't be prohibited but they
aren't
i believe this bill will will entice
people to prohibit them
in order to take the lowest bid
it's typical when you get federal money
massachusetts is a good example
when the federal money rolls in and you
bid on work in massachusetts
is basically what i would call a pla
everybody has to pay
some people know it as bacon davis act
um new hampshire contractors are allowed
to go into mass but but you have to pay
the going rate and and you have to treat
your people the same
i honestly believe that the intent of
this bill is to
ice out anybody who or
keep out anybody who has
um
decent wages
whether they're union or non-union
um if if i'm going to go in a bid
against people who are allowed to have
an entire force of subcontractors with
no workers comp no insurances
i'm not going to bother bidding so i
think that what happens when you put
something like this out there you say to
people don't bother
to bid here go to work in mass or
someplace else um we'll we'll take the
cheap labor it's it's a problem because
i believe the quality of the work goes
down
when you say you don't have to be a
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
morning bob
so the statement was made in response to
a question that i asked of an earlier
individual who referenced the fact that
this type of legislation
is in effect in about 20 other states
and i said do they have any experience
with the bills or is it in
these agreements in pla these
legislation
bills are they in effect in other states
so that we can say
with some degree of a certain certitude
that the bill works
the legislation works and he said
that they don't have any he was not
aware of any of them having any problems
do you have any experience with other
states that have this type of
legislation in place
every state i've done work for has has
basically what i would call pla
requirements you you can't bid on on a
project with them without following
certain criteria
and you might as well say it's it's it's
almost like being part of the union but
you know before you go in what the
criteria is
so instead of waiting for somebody to
come in and he says well you didn't tell
me i had to have liability insurance on
everybody or you didn't have to tell you
didn't tell me how to have workers comp
whether they're subcontractors
at that point it's too late you're
already the low bidder and if you've got
the job who's who's responsible for that
in some cases
it's the state who's had to pick up the
difference
so i don't know about other states i
only know the the new england states
i think we still call new york or new
england state but
um i've worked in hartford connecticut
having a pla of some sort and i'm not
saying a union peeler having a pla to
work off of makes it so much easier
to be competitive
thank you
okay
i'm just going to ask for paul because
if it's one of those names can you spell
well i'm a frenchman so i'll spell my
dear madame chair members of the house
executive departments and administration
committee my name is paul grenier
and i reside at 492 champlain street in
berlin i'm a lifelong resident of berlin
and currently am serving my seventh term
as mayor of the city of berlin
i also serve as a coast county
commissioner representing berlin
shelburne randolph
i am here to present testimony to
strongly urge you to oppose
senate bill 274
the bill that would essentially
allow out of state workers to overtake
any publicly funded capital improvement
project in our state
mr grenier
if i may interrupt you for a moment sure
if you could please um just kind of
highlight what your written testimony is
instead of actually just reading it to
us okay thank you sure
all right let me go to the back page
and i'll read
my personal experience of pla provide me
with a stock reminder of the value of
keeping our locals working
over 12 years ago when walmart came to
gorham to erect a superstore there
the contractor brought laborers not only
from out of state but from out of
country there were some arrests for
being in the country illegally
while not one single laborer from the
berlin gorham area was hired to do the
work
three years later bell heary a non-pla
contractor was awarded the contract to
bill fci berlin
though bell hirey did hire many locals
most of the workforce was from outside
coast county
they provided work for many but did not
offer young people a chance to learn a
trade
the following year babcock and wilcox
with a pla signed
with a developer of burgess biopower
built the 75 megawatt power plant
the vast majority of the labor force was
from coast county
and as part of a structured agreement
between k street capital
and myself with the city of berlin
the different building trades all
started apprenticeship programs
many of the 18 to 25 year olds with
little construction backgrounds but a
motivated willingness to learn a
lifelong skill
were hired by the union halls
it is a success story for these young
productive adults
a chance that they more likely would not
have been given if not for the new
hampshire building trades crafts
senate bill 274 was written without
consulting federal government agencies
that hold the power to assist new
hampshire's efforts to repair roads and
bridges
it was written without consideration for
its potential impact on towns and cities
affordable housing and infrastructure
project
and was clearly written as a solution in
search of a problem as new hampshire has
never in its entire history
had a project labor agreement on
state-funded construction projects
on behalf of berlin in the north country
i ask you to please kill sb 274
a short-sighted bill that would impede
our state's ability to receive millions
of dollars in federal infrastructure
funds
and if pass
will only fill the pockets of a few big
shark contractors at the expense of our
great new hampshire skilled craftsmen
and women
i'd be glad to take any questions
thank you mayor are there any questions
representative marsh uh yes thank you
madam chair and thank you mayor for
coming all the way down here to see us
it's quite a long trip and i'm glad to
see you in person uh your next to last
paragraph there about the federal
agencies uh are you essentially
answering my question to senator bradley
as to whether this bill would make it
impossible for the new hampshire to
access the competitive grants to the
department of transportation i think the
way the bill is written the language is
so nebulous that we're going to be
feeding lawyers and not paying
contractors
it makes zero sense to me
thank you you know we're trying to fix a
problem that doesn't exist
representative goalie
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking the question
in hearing your testimony on the last
few paragraphs
is it my understanding and your
experience
we heard earlier testimony that this
bill before us would protect new
hampshire workers and companies
it sounds to me like apla protected the
north country workers and companies is
that not correct well i don't want to
wait in the waters of speculation all i
can talk about is my experience
when babcock and wilcox came to berlin i
sat down
with babcock and wilcox and then joe
casey from the new hampshire building
trades council
and we worked out an agreement where the
billing trades would hire
a bunch of
young
berlin gorham residents to learn trades
and there were approximately a hundred
new people learning a trade and all the
various trades on that three-year
construction project
today most of them people still live in
berlin they are living they're working
jobs that have a livable wage they're
productive members of berlin and without
that project they probably would have
left
what a crime that would be
thank you very much are there any
further questions representative schuett
thank you madam chair
and mayor i'm guessing that those young
folks are paying taxes to the town of
berlin is that correct they pay taxes
and i coach a lot of their kids because
they've been around long enough i coach
their kids in youth hockey so it's
you know life comes full circle
you you know what if we don't take care
of our young people and we don't try
to
to keep our young kids working
what you're gonna you plant corn you get
morning madam chair
committee
my name is paul de laurie i live in beau
new hampshire
and i am vice president of hampshire
fire protection company we're
headquartered in londonderry new
hampshire
and i'm here in support of sb 274.
we have regional offices in swansea new
hampshire and in west lebanon new
hampshire
and our company employs approximately
175 new hampshire residents
and we are a proud merit shop company
our primary business is to install
water-based fire protection systems in
commercial industrial buildings
hospitals schools
large apartment buildings
our company self performs design
fabrication and installation of the fire
sprinkler systems by
skilled tradesmen
known as sprinkler fitters
our company also provides fire alarm
kitchen hood
we might be
considered the
destination employer for our trade we
provide
fire sprinkler services and fire alarm
construction
for
most of the work that's private and
public in the state of new hampshire we
are the
say the big fish in the small pond
we regularly furnish and install systems
at the university of new hampshire
plymouth state university keene state
government buildings
we're currently installing a system at
the government
dams bureau off of silk farm road
our our company is opposed to project
labor agreements
as those work rules and the methods of
delivering those construction services
are not conducive to our company's ways
and means of producing our work
when there are project labor agreements
you've essentially
mandated that my company will be not
afforded
the opportunity
to bid on the project
our 175 employees and let's say their
two dependents
would make up 525 people that would be
affected
by not having the opportunity to even
bid on a job
we've had experience uh with project
labor agreement opposition in the past
there was a job course center that was
federal in in manchester years ago
fortunately the project did not go with
a pla had it gone with a pla at the time
we would not have participated
the project ended up getting built
without a pla and my company was
successful bitter
to design furnish and install the fire
protection system
so if plas are to be
put forward in a meaningful way
hampshire fire protection will not
participate and the state
would not be afforded
thank you so my impression from
listening to testimony this morning is
that
small businesses in new hampshire
don't favor plas
and i wanted to ask you
why
you would not bid on a project with a
pla
well as a merit shop contractor um
we are determining our
our employee relationship and it's
subject to that um
say agreement that we have as a private
employer
who's not subjected or beholding to a
our employees
choose to work for our company
based on our merit shop philosophy
it's it's not a question of whether or
not one is better than the other it is
their choice
we provide
great benefits wages
401k holidays
company vehicles
our our skilled tradesmen are our
professional people
in all of the supporting
people who provide design fabrication
accounting all of those people are
going to be denied work opportunities
directly or indirectly on project labor
agreement type projects because
those
work rules and
affiliations
are not
in sync with our merit shop philosophy
thank you
representative fellows
um
so i'm not expert in this but i'm trying
to understand why you think
you wouldn't be able to participate
because
you know if you have good benefits and
do do you use
subcontractors
we self-employ
all of our
our labor they're genuine employees of
our company they're they're not
from a union hall
they are direct employees of hampshire
fire protection
and um
we are a merit shop company we are not a
union shop company and and therefore a
pla
with
labor
affiliations that would cause us to have
to
become
essentially union is a non-starter for
us
follow-up
up
so
maybe i don't understand but
um what i had been hearing
is that these agreements don't necess
don't make you
don't require
at least in some cases to hire union
employees
they have provisions that say like you
have to pay the prevailing wage
you know and and you can't use you know
you can't use
you can't use sub contractors people who
are really
just employees but some people call them
subcontractors so they don't have to do
the workers comp and don't have to give
them benefits so i'm i'm not entirely
are you sure that this you would be
excluded
from you from being a subcontract i mean
you're not going to bid on these
projects anyway these are big
representatives please don't please
don't debate the witness just ask ask
your question and let him answer i am
i'm trying to because my understanding
is that this is not
for
just like a retro fit that you might be
doing for a building but that these are
big construction projects and your
we are a specialty contractor and we do
work with prime contractors or
construction managers who would execute
that prime contract
uh say with with the the owner or the
state
our employees are truly our employees
with with full benefits we pay all of
our workers comp we
we apply all the requirements
for
proper classification of employees and
wages it's not
to be that we are less than
it's that the
project labor agreements are such that
the
rules and the necessity to adhere to
union labor type rules
aren't ones that we in the merit shop
community
um adhere to and if there's a
pla those rules would be in effect in in
that's incongruous with with who we are
as merit shop contractors
representative
just
can you just just decide
just to find merit shop because i don't
know what that means
merit shop is essentially uh as the name
would
be uh
defined by webster's that that uh
pay and advancement is defined based on
one's skills and aptitude and it is not
subject to
um
you know time in grade or or some type
of seniority if you're
if you're good at your work
you perform at a level that is
exceptional then you you get rewarded
with paying advancement based on that
merit
representative
goalie thank you madam chair thank you
for taking the question i i just want to
be sure that i understand that if
and
from what i've heard in testimony new
hampshire has never had a contract that
required a pla
that
if there was a pla
your choice to bid on the con bit not
bid on the contract is your choice
that
it doesn't preclude you from bidding on
the contract just because it is a pla
it's your choice not to bid is that
correct
that's correct we would choose not to
bid on a pla project
based on the union work rules that would
be in effect and in so doing
there's a special carve out for that
type of labor versus say 90 percent of
construction work
that is merit shop
i i will be denied or my employees and
their dependents will be denied
opportunity
if a pla
representative
thank you madam chair so just to confirm
if if this bill didn't pass and a pla
were instituted on a job you're saying
your firm would be denied the right to
bid
it's not my my my right to bid it is my
choice okay because
i can't i am i will not be subjected to
the union uh uh project labor
arrangements or or rules that are in
effect based on the pla these these are
these are onerous rules
that that i am
not going to be adhering to and i don't
adhere to them in the private sector
currently
thank you
follow up i just i just wanted to
confirm because i keep hearing
precluded from bidding denied
bidding
and and i'm just trying to find out if
that's the case you will be you won't
you won't be allowed i believe that the
that the witnesses answered that
question i think three three times thank
you very much
i i have not seen a pla
are you requi
how involved how involved is it
it sounds like you're deputized to be in
the union or have to follow all of their
rules is it that extensive i think it
would appear that it's
you've got to do reasonable things
follow osha follow workman's
compensation uh
wages are specified but beyond that
is there do all the work rules come with
this
is that your objection i don't quite see
why it's so
burdensome for you
we
we abide by all the rules already so it
the the pla isn't going to uh cause us
to do something uh that we're not
already doing already
besides the union requirements that the
finer points of the language and the
agreement would uh
pertain to
and it
would have us have to be beholden to
other decision makers who are providing
those work rules that are
union-driven
work rules
and we are a merit shop company and and
we are not going to be subjected to
those
thank you very much
representative o'brien thank you madam
chair i will be brief uh thank you sir
for taking my question it sounds like
you're a good businessman and uh you
have a very successful business i am
aware of it but if this bill gets
defeated
you still would have a very successful
it's likely i will continue to be
successful i i don't like the notion of
a special carve out
in denying my company and my employees
opportunity
um you know if i'm doing business now
um i would like the opportunity to do
business on the next big project that's
involved with the state
and not have it be that we're going to
have to pass
because of a pla
you've essentially tied my hands
when it becomes a pla and even if i am
say a dominant fire sprinkler company
the state's not going to have the
benefit
thank you we'll leave that thank you
thank you sir
good morning thank you madam chair
members of the committee
um my name is joe casey i am
international representative for the
ibew
and i was the past president of the new
hampshire building construction trades
and involved with the
the federal project labor agreement that
was spoken of
earlier on the job corps center
on behalf of
the building trades
i represented them
and i would like to
if i could
base my testimony just on that issue and
then uh
you have any questions i'll i'll take
them
um so
in indeed the federal department of
labor
put forward a
mandated
project labor agreement
on the
of the building construction of the job
corps center in new hampshire job corps
center in manchester new hampshire
contractors in new hampshire
project labor agreement
and
um the project was delayed and went into
um
uh
arbitration and on all kinds of issues
uh that transpired
uh this was a period of time
we had you know quite a bit of
construction at the time we had about 30
000 construction workers
the construction industry was growing
um
and
you know we were looking forward to um
you know proven
proving that uh a project labor
agreement
on a
uh government
construction job uh would be beneficial
to the state
and to the workforce here in the state
under
we had already had a series of
procurement new hampshire state
procurement
bills that were put forward
here in the state of new hampshire to
try to address a lot of the concerns
that we spoke about that was spoken
about earlier
and senator clegg
was on that was on that committee
um and opposed to the building trades
and where we were on a lot of these
issues
it was during those hearings that a lot
of this information came out
about
how construction workers were being
treated on job sites all throughout the
state of new hampshire now obviously we
have a lot of great contractors that are
non-union in the state of new hampshire
we have a lot of great contractors that
are union
but we also have a lot that um
take advantage of their workforce and
that was the basis of the project labor
agreement that we were working on
to try to prove that it would have been
a benefit with the worker in the state
of new hampshire
where workers
would have had representation they would
have they would have made
the wages
for their craft that they were supposed
to make
in all of that
and uh
after
the challenge went through
um
they uh they took away the project labor
agreement job was re-bid
contractor got the job
um
and it was essentially a 100 non-union
project
that was taken place
because of the fact that we lost the
project labor agreement when we were
trying we were trying to um
uh
you know make a point and show
how
the young worker in the state of new
hampshire
uh
was not interested becoming interested
in the in the industry anymore
um
we followed the project by
the freedom
information act in pulling the payroll
from the job so that we can make sure
that although the job was not under a
project labor agreement
all of the employers were still subject
to have to pay
the davis bacon rates because it was a
federally funded project
and
the first couple of months they did
and then about the third month
um we noticed that
some of the trades most
uh most significantly the trades that
were working on the civil portion of the
project
we're now making about five six dollars
an hour less than that they were making
the previous month
i contacted the department of labor or
the u.s department of labor
and asked what the deal was with that
and um
the winning contractor for the for the
project had solicited the department of
labor for a new davis bacon rate
which was significantly less the job was
bid under building our contractors
bidded under building
and they changed it to the heavy
category
which allowed the employer to now cut
wages
uh in some cases up to six dollars an
hour
so
this was in 2009
[Music]
by the time the project had started
the world in construction had fallen
apart at that point
we were down about 12 000 workers in the
state of new hampshire
because of the crisis in the economy
and these people just basically didn't
have any other place to go
and
that
that's exactly
what this project labor agreement was
supposed to was supposed to stop and
prove
decision
i in the building trades we appealed the
decision by the department of labor and
well after the project was complete
the department of labor said that they
did air in making that decision and they
should never have allowed that to happen
so there is
the poster child project
that is cited as far as
as far as um
why we should not have project labor
agreements and what have you here in the
state of new hampshire
and the very project turned out to be a
disgrace for the worker
now these are the young workers right
who
our dads
and uh grandfathers
that we expect to send
their kids and their grandkid children
into the trades
and will now wonder why we can't find
any help
throughout the state from the workforce
and why nobody wants to come into the
trades it's the last place you're going
to see people like that sending their
kids including me
um and uh and i'll tell you it's uh
it's
we're in a real world of hurt as far as
bringing trying to bring in uh
young kids young workers or those that
worked in the trade
half of the half of the construction
workers that are worth anything in the
state of new hampshire right now
and we're wondering where they are and
why they're not working on new hampshire
projects across from the border and
working in massachusetts they didn't
have that opportunity before they do now
now project labor agreement's not going
to solve all our pro
all our problems
but there's a reason why we have lost a
lot of workers and we continue to do so
and if we really want to um
start looking at how we're going to
increase
you know
the young kids
and
want them to come into the trades
these are some of the tools that we can
use
if we show choose to do so if not we
don't have to it's just a tool taking it
off the table
and just you know cable
no municipality anybody that has state
funding on on a project
will not be able to do so uh is just
ridiculous considering the fact
that i can't see it happening
it has never happened
and
you know it probably won't
but if a municipality certainly wanted
to use that tool
to put some people in their high school
to work on a project
if any shape or form any work force
agreement in any shape or form
would now be illegal and that's exactly
what how this is worded
and it's wrong
and uh that concludes my testimony thank
you
but this hearing has run into two other
bills which i'm going to reschedule for
the afternoon so we can fin we will
finish up the hearing here and then go
to lunch and do the other two bills of
the afternoon and i apologize to all of
you for having
this
uh
for scheduling this ceiling actually
um
it'll be directly after
mr chair
yes sir representative judy yes thank
you thank you chair
uh mr
mr casey
i am really sorry um
i miss you part of your testimony
you are for the bill or you are against
i'm sorry i didn't say to begin with
i am opposed to the bill
anyone else
the chair calls
josh reap
yeah and i want to be i want to be
sensitive to people's time and thank you
for letting me speak today uh in lieu of
my written testimony which is being
passed out i just wanted to
hit on a couple of uh points that are in
my written testimony because i think
they're germaine and relate a lot to the
questions and conversations been
happening so i'll stick mostly to that
uh my name for the record is joshua
reeve i'm from manchester new hampshire
but i represent associate builders and
contractors which is based in concord
we represent over 260 merit shop or open
shop contractors here in new hampshire
and a few in vermont
but ultimately our contractors uh
do bid private public work every day
and they provide a lot of good quality
construction you see even here in this
building and next door in the capitol
and across the entire campus here
throughout concord
um ultimately for us
project labor agreements it should be
left up to the contractor because it's
one of those work rule tools that are
utilized by contractors if they choose
to
there's a lot of confusion earlier about
what the state requires you don't need a
pla to guarantee workers comp if someone
is a citizen if someone's got insurance
and bonding all that's established by
state law already
so if there's a general contractor
around here that chooses someone on to
as a roofer
for their sub as a roofer that is
employable illegal illegal
workers i question that general
contractors work ethic but in general
our contractors don't do that they are
pre-vetted by the state they are high
quality high performing contractors
and for us just in general
i'd like to point out the fact that
we're having this conversation today
it's very passion on both sides
shows you that this legislation is very
necessary because there's a lot of talk
out of the beltway in politics in dc
about implementing mandates in a variety
of parts of life including in
construction with a pla mandate now
again if a contractor chooses to use a
pla that works well for them
but let me tell you the problems when
you have a government mandated pla and
why we need this bill to prevent them
from ever happening
they are effectively a one size fits all
and when a general contractor is told by
the state you have to divide by this pla
and all your subs have to abide by all
the work rules in there too it throws
out any kind of collective bargaining
agreement those subs had or any
relationship they had with their
employees and that's the problem when
the government mandates a pla
it also removes certain efficiencies
that a contractor may have with their
workforce a guy here from this hampshire
fire talked about his merit workforce he
directly employs his individuals and
they work out what the work rules look
like in processes when you jumble in a
pla from the government the government
says here's one size fits all you need
to work within that scope they go what
the hell i can't work with that because
we
aren't familiar with those broke rules
it may work for some contractors but not
for us
it removes
pathways into construction now the sure
pla can include them but it limits which
ones they are under a project labor
agreement an open shop contractor with
an apprentice program
can't use their apprentices on the
project it eliminates that pathway into
into the careers in construction because
what happens is the pla says you have to
use an apprentice program recognized by
the local union hall that's fine for a
union contractor because that's where
they borrow their labor from but for a
merit shop or open shop contractor
when you're told you can't use your
apprentices on a project or you can't
use your apprentice program on the
project what's the point of even having
one anymore because that closes the door
of opportunity for craft workers in the
state
there's also something i want to mention
too
you know the benefits right there's a
question earlier to someone about
one of the challenges of why you
wouldn't want to bid a government
mandated pla project it's very simple
under a project labor agreement when
it's mandated by the government
it says where the benefits go the
benefits has to go through the union
hall now if i'm an open shop or
non-union contractor and i bid on a job
the government says i have to use a cba
or collect collective bargaining
agreement under a pla
all that benefit package goes through
the union hall my worker is not going to
be on that job long enough to meet the
investment requirements of that union's
program so what happens is an open shop
contractor i'm paying double benefits
i'm paying to a union hall for the
privilege of working on this public work
project
and i'm paying my worker separately for
their 401k
their healthcare and their apprentice
fund separately because that's what a
good employer would do that's an example
of some of the increased costs that come
when you have a government mandated pla
and ultimately at the end of the day
this bill is about just making sure that
as new hampshire as government we don't
start putting in requirements that
aren't necessary there's some talk
earlier about some of the investment
recovery funds that are coming from the
federal government so let's say a state
agency applies for it in that grant
language it talks about having local
labor local hire and local
project labor agreement discussions with
local labor you could still do all that
under this bill the very last portion
talks about exemptions all it says is if
you still want to do a pla you got to
have a public hearing if you're going to
talk about a pla which amends state
contract laws in a completely different
way and foreign to new hampshire you got
to at least have conversations so
situations like this like you have today
you have the diverse opinions that come
into factoring whether or not that works
for the local workforce and the local
contractors
that's ultimately what that's about on
the end of it the exemptions on that
and one of the other points i want to
make on the bill the reason why there
are some references to those rsas
is because we want to make sure that if
if a municipality goes to the state and
says we want this carve out please give
it to us there's not going to be some
state agency bad actor is going to say
well you got to do it my way you got to
do it with a pla or without a pla it's
your choice by the way because that's
ultimately what the rest of the bill
says on here so the bill as it says is
it merits now if the state is a direct
a direct
contract holder on this that project
won't have a mandated pla but if a
municipality or someone else wants to
get an exemption for something it's just
saying the state won't mandate that they
have a pla on it
so um i know that we've been here for a
while and you know i'm happy answering
any other questions i hope i clear
clarified some that may already be out
there
nice job thank you very much
representative lucas
um thank you it appears there weren't
enough copies your written test wanted
to go around possible please email it to
the committee absolutely i'll do that by
end today thank you thank you thank you
see no further questions thank you very
much thank you
before i call the the next witness to
testify i would ask that
please keep your testimony to
information that the committee has not
already heard from a prior witness
if you believe that you're going to just
kind of regurgitate the same thing we've
already heard if you could just um
please wave off that would be fantastic
um
mr
gilbert
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee i appreciate the opportunity
to speak with you today
my name is john gilbert i'm the
president of martino electric we're an
electrical contractor in dover we have
25 employees and the company is 100
employee owned through an employee stock
ownership plan
briefly we employ local people we pay
competitive wages we offer excellent
benefits and we train our people
thoroughly and carefully and we have a
very strong focus on safety
mandated plas would introduce a number
of unknowns into our efforts to provide
efficient and effective results for our
customers
it would force us to introduce
inequities into our compensation
programs
and our management program internally by
bringing in union workers that are paid
and managed differently than our
employees inducing
harmful stresses within within the
organization
in addition outside workers that we have
not developed trained and worked with
would be a wild card for us with respect
to quality productivity and possibly
safety we simply would not know them the
way that we know our own people
our costs would therefore be higher to
hedge against uncertainty which is
inefficient for the customer
this uncertainty i would note adds
substantially to the considerable
uncertainty we already face with the
availability and costs of construction
materials
our people care very deeply
about the quality of their work the
customers the company and they have
chosen to work in a merit-based model
because of their desire to do great work
as efficiently as possible
we believe that plas are not aligned
with that model
we are confident that the business
leaders and owners in our industry are
in the best position to decide the right
model for their businesses without
government involvement influencing labor
management practices
we respectfully request that you support
sb 274 to preserve our ability our
business's ability to operate in the
most efficient and effective manner in
the interests of our customers
thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions
representative goalie
thank you madam chair thank you for
has
the way the current law is written now
prevented you from
as the as as
currently this this law is not in place
so in the absence of this law no we have
not been prevented from from bidding on
contracts
would this law prevent you from being
follow-up
yes we would be disinclined for the very
reasons that you heard from the
gentleman from the sprinkler company
it'd be the same same issue you know we
have
established internal management
practices and procedures we would be
required to bring some in that do not
comport with the ones that we have
chosen to use
and that would be a factor in deciding
whether we were going to bid on the
project or not one last follow-up
so that decision on whether or not you
bid on the contract isn't because it's a
pla it's a business decision on your
behalf correct it's a business decision
thank you very much
thank you madam chairman
members of the committee i will keep my
comments short
my name is rodney bartlett i'm the
director of business development for
methuen construction they're
headquartered out of plaistow new
hampshire we've been in business over 50
years
we employ between two and 300 employees
annually
uh we are a merit-based shop and you go
on to our website you'll be very clear
to notice is a team effort
the entire company works together as a
team we go on a job site each crew is a
team
and i'm going to use one quick example
as to how that differs
from other organizations
and i'm going to use the example of a
steel reinforced concrete retaining wall
we go on site the team crew chief
has his members
they form the footing
pour the concrete
tie the rebar
put the
reinforcing panels in place pour the
concrete
strip the wall and begin the backfill
process they do that as the team
together the same crew
under other scenarios
you would look at the carpenters union
to come in to form the footing
the steel workers to do the rebar in the
reinforcing
the labor crew to to help pour the
concrete
the carpets to push and pieces in place
pour the concrete with the concrete
laborers
carpenters come back to strip that and
then another crew comes in to do the
earth work
essentially the same product at the end
but clearly you can see that the
effectiveness and efficiency
is going to be less
so our model of our merit-based model
working truly as a team throughout the
company is what we believe makes us
different and has kept us a successful
thank you
representative fellows
thank you um i understand the steps that
you just went went through it sounds
sounds a lot like um putting down
putting in the foundation for a house
so do you um have a lot of jobs that are
on
big projects like 20 like 30 million
dollar projects or do you do more
like residential kinds of things most of
our projects are in excess of 10 million
dollars
uh we're presently working with
manchester waterworks on their new well
and treatment system in hooksett which
was nearly 40 million dollars
we are in the process of completing the
renovations and expansion of the the
merrimack wastewater treatment plant
we have a project at the portsmouth
naval shipyard that's in excess of 60
million dollars
so we do large projects
follow up
so are are you the the contractor that
bid on this or are you a subcontractor
we are the contractor okay thanks
and thank you for no questions
good morning madam chair
uh in committee
i am opposed to build 274
my name is leonard delgato and i'm with
the international union of operating
engineers
local 98.
uh you did say regurgitate you don't
want to have anybody regurgitate the
same thing over and over and and i'm
going to step off into a little
different area myself
uh and share some of the behind the
scenes nuts and bolts if i may
uh
our men and women operate the heavy
equipment that you see as you drive
around on projects bulldozers
cranes excavators
and that such
uh
we have a school
that we train these young men and women
in an apprenticeship that lasts three
years
every year we open it up to the public
and we get high school kids and young
adults
that don't know where their future is
going to be
and we take them and then train them
it starts off with classes
and then moves out to our 40 acre
sandbox
to utilize all this equipment that we
have to train them on
efficiently
the manufacturers
are updating this equipment with all
electronic
computers
and this must also be taught to them
so they can use it efficiently
also in our classroom there's the osha
rules and regulations
which are there for safety
for our fellow workers for all the other
trades
and on public streets where you drive by
us
to secure
part of our
apprenticeship
as their skill gets better
they are allowed to go out on jobs when
they are proficient in a or that
piece of equipment and are on the
tutelage of a senior operator to learn
the do's
and the don'ts
uh
i'd like to allow
the questions if anybody has any and
good morning madam chair and committee
i'll be very brief my name is stephen
chasey
i'm the president and owner of sl chasey
steele in hudson new hampshire
we employ 175 people in new hampshire
with much like hampshire fire protection
we're a subcontractor on a job
all our employees are our own employees
i started the company when i was 23
with one person myself
i've hired everybody
we've trained everybody we have
certified welders we're a certified
steel company
i have an agreement with my employees
my labor agreement
we're a big family
add a project labor agreement to a
project that we're bidding on is not
needed for a company like ours or most
of the other 90 of the companies in new
hampshire
most companies are family companies
very highly skilled
generations and generations of families
um
to add something like this to my company
would not work as it wouldn't work with
like i said 90 of the the other
non-union contractors we pay workers
comp
we don't hire subcontractors
you know as
like most of the other companies in new
hampshire
but i disagree with the spill
strongly
um
and that's that's pretty much pretty
much it thank you
thank you very much
representative schmidt
so
so i i didn't quite hear your final
statement so you say you i disagree with
the people you disagree
you don't want this bill i'm sorry
he opposes the bill representative elias
okay thank you thank you
i thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
glenn brackett i'm the president of the
new hampshire afl-cio
we represent 55 unions and almost 100
000 working families here in new
hampshire
coming here today to weigh in against sb
and as uh
mr delgado said i'm not going to waste
any more time a couple of things i
wanted to clarify from previous
statement
number one it is a violation of federal
law for any company to be excluded from
a project labor agreement union
non-union whatever it's a violation of
the law
if an employer chooses not to
participate that's their choice it's not
the law says they can choose
the reason we've never had a project
labor agreement state funded here in new
hampshire is because
we are never the low bid
we come in we bid the job wages benefits
and working conditions
the independent the so-called merit
shops come in they don't pay the same
thing that we do and that
and what ends up happening is that we're
not low bid
now why are we trying to pass
a bill
that would say
even if you get the job with low bid you
can't have it because that's what this
legislation says
so that's the one thing i wanted to
clear up number two competition
due to the fact that everyone is
entitled to compete for these jobs when
someone tells you ninety percent of the
companies in this state can't
participate they're not being accurate
every company in this state can
participate in a project labor agreement
if they choose not to well hey i don't
shop at walmart should we have a bill
that no one can shop at walmart it's
unfair
what i did pass to the clerk was a copy
of the transportation
the requirements from the department of
transportation for federal money
uh it's 75 pages long so please excuse
me for not killing 10 000 trees
um
a couple of things we have to look at
no one that was questioned today could
give an answer to what happens with
federal money in this with this bill
going through
i'm different i called the department of
labor
i spoke to the commerce department i
spoke to the transportation department
and i spoke to the white house and i'll
tell you this
if this bill passes sb 274 becomes law
in this state federal money is in risk
coming into this state
the mayor of manchester has written a
letter that she's looking at 80 million
dollars coming in on the 80 million
dollars coming in there's a percentage
of that money which is
uh cost sharing or a match by the state
government
so manchester's looking at an 80 million
dollar infrastructure project and this
bill has every ability to sideline that
this is a bill
that isn't necessary
if we had an issue where we've always
been doing this and it was unfair that
would make sense
we've never done it
if it's about competition
competition's there it's the law
it's about fairness
fairness is there it's the law
changing this law to suit the needs of
some people that have a political or
ideological agenda that they don't want
to get involved in project or labor
agreements
that is strictly 100 their choice
not mine so that is the extent of my
testimony and i'd be more than willing
to take some questions
representative
thank you um maybe you can
clarify something i don't understand and
that is uh
i think the law of the bill explicitly
says that you can't require plas but
also you can't prohibit them
but i thought i heard you say that if
this were passed then even if um
the people you're involved with were the
low bidders they still could not been on
the project i don't see how that is
correct given the bill if the language
says that you can't use state money for
state money for a contract with the cba
if that's what if that that's where the
intent of the bill is
follow up cba
contract i'm sorry collective bargaining
agreement
union contract union contract uh
follow-up i i think the bill maybe i'm
wrong and you can point out where i am
but i think the bill explicitly says
that
you you can't require a pla but also you
cannot prohibit a pla i think what my
testimony says representative is that
the federal government has requirements
when they bring um stimula uh
infrastructure packages into the state
and again i'll reference you to the the
the package that i gave the the the
clerk
that specifically specifically that if
we're going to have no project labor
agreements in new hampshire then the
ability to get federal funding is in
jeopardy
follow-up you recognize follow-up thank
you
yeah i mean i wasn't
i wasn't talking about the federal
projects i was talking about ones funded
by the state and you've said that if
we're not going bill doesn't say we're
not going to have
collective bargaining agreements or plas
at least that's my understanding if you
can point in the bill where it says that
please do so i don't have the bill in
front of me but i would i would say that
i would stick to my main point that if
we if this legislation does pass we are
not eligible for federal funding
all right thank you
thank you representative are there any
thank you very much thank you madam
chair at this time i am oh has anybody
in the audience want to testify that has
not signed up to testify
seeing none i will close the public
yes
is
facebook
okay
you can look at this
see
we're here yeah so if you want to look
are any of the sponsors of senate bill
no in that case representative schmidt
since you're the closest if you'd care
2 26 at 1 pm
2 25 at
good afternoon committee
uh for the record peter schmidt
representing dover awards one and two
which is stratford
19.
i'm happy to
open senate bill 226 fn
establishing a recruitment and retention
program for state employment
was not yet here
but
and i'll take notes sorry represent
well fine thank you representative
schmidt we appreciate your introducing
it
oh yes
senator d'alessandro you're on you're on
deck
uh come before you as the prime sponsor
of senate bill 226
fn establishing a retent recruitment and
retention policy
for the state of new hampshire
the bill pastor said it was amended in
the senate
and
uh currently
we have 10 604 total positions that are
classified in the state of new hampshire
we have
1967 vacancies
that's 18.6 percent
we have 407
full-time temporary listings that's up
to six months we have 185 vacancies
that's 45.4 percent
unclassified full-time we have 427 we
have 69 vacancies that's 15.5
totally we have 11 428 jobs in the state
of new hampshire we have
2221 that are unfilled
that's
19.4 percent
so the vacancy rate of the state is
approximately 20
i've got a breakdown of all of where
these vacancies occur but clearly we
needed to go in a new direction
and recruitment and retention are vital
for the state of new hampshire
recruiting the best possible people
and retaining the best possible people
this bill allows for that process to
begin
directed by
our
des agency and uh
that's that's it we have we have a
crying need for people
this is one way to try to recruit and
retain people
and
admin services knows how difficult this
is people are here from admin services
that can comment on this but
when you have this many vacancies for
this long period of time
state government can't function as
effectively and efficiently
as it has in in the past and that
creates uh that creates problems i think
i've stated to do this to you before
madam chairman
that if we could fill every vacancy at
new hampshire hospital
we would have no waiting list
currently waiting lists exist for both
children and adults
so if we could fill these jobs
we wouldn't have vacancies that would be
in the best interest of the public in
order in order to do that
so uh you know with that i'll address
any questions as i say people are here
from admin services who can go over the
specifics and can go over the amendment
the amendment to the bill uh
sets a process in place where you go
here you go there to get together excuse
me senator is that the amendment that
you adopted in the senate yes it is okay
well then we don't need to
know the details because that is the
bill as well that's cool that's correct
wonderful thank you thank you for that
clarification madam chairman i couldn't
figure it out myself but that's okay
thank you you don't need to try to
confuse us we do just fine on our own
confusion is the byword of the
legislature
mass confusion is even more important
senator d'allesandro this is i have an
uncomfortable question
um don't you think state government
the departments and state government are
striving mightily to do this on their
own what rabbit do you think can be
pulled out of the hat the rabbit of
course is more money but that's not
quite on the table well
thank you thank you very much for the
question i'm sure
that that at each department is working
diligently to fill its vacancies but as
you know the vacancies are there the
vacancies haven't been filled this is
another methodology to put in place to
aid the departments in their search for
quality individuals but more important
to retain
quality individuals
so it's a it's another it's another
little thing in in the rabbit's hat
we call it a plus
thank you senator you're welcome pearson
thank you madam chair thank you senator
d'alessandro
for taking my question
so
aside from looking at
a veto proof majority of senators that
are even co-sponsors of this i'm trying
to understand
the this is not a commission
or a committee so this is this is sort
i'm trying
i'm trying to understand just the
methodology here that would
be employed to to come up with
this because as an example we in this
committee we see the
gentleman from
personnel and we have a lot of
interaction with jcec as far as
classifications and we heard testimony
earlier in reference to
their inability to modify
pay grades based on market yes things
that are going on so
with this
i like the idea don't get me wrong i'm
just trying to wrap my brain around
how what this looks like since it's not
a committee or a commission okay well
thank you for the question i think
cassie kane
and
her
director
and director laurie could uh be very
helpful in giving you a clear and
succinct explanation
sometimes i cloud the issue they're
they're getting the assignment to do the
work so i think we should ask them what
it involves
are there any other questions for the
senator
seeing none thank you very much thank
you madame very much madam chair
pleasure to be here
good afternoon my name is uh cassie
keenum the deputy commissioner of the
department of administrative services
and i'm here with laurie rudis who's the
director of the division of first
so um
we proposed this legislation and worked
with senator d'alessandro because
as as the data he shared with you
[Music]
reveals we have been facing
significant
vacancy rates throughout state
government and often in very significant
positions he mentioned for example new
hampshire hospital commissioner hanks is
here department of corrections has has
significant vacancies nurses corrections
officers engineers
child protection workers
and
we've been racking our brain over the
years of working together about what
could we do differently to try and
recruit people to these difficult
positions
so
one of the tools that we do not have in
our tool chest today is proposed in this
legislation and it it would give the
director of the division of personnel
authority to establish a program to pay
incentives for recruitment and retention
so
so to get to the heart of representative
pearson's question
how does this work
if you look at the bill
it says the department shall obtain the
approval of the fiscal committee of the
general court prior to development
developing and implementing the program
so
this would be enabling legislation that
director reuters would then work with
her staff and with our commissioner's
office to establish the parameters of
a paid incentive program for recruitment
and retention
and and when we settle on what that
model looks like the the first thing i
think we have to do under this bill is
to go to fiscal committee and get their
approval
and that is required in line four and
five
and um
that would that would lay out what would
this program look like and i'll let
laurie talk a little bit to that
but i also want to just further answer
representative pearson's question
because if you go over to page two
line ones through three
it says that any expenditures for
recruitment and retention incentives or
bonuses pursuant to this paragraph shall
require the approval of the fiscal
committee for the general court so the
way i see this um this authority
structure in here being is that the
fiscal committee wants to see the
program before it's up and running and
then
as any agency decides that it would like
to offer a
a recruitment or attention or retention
incentive that they would have to go to
fiscal committee and get that permission
before they could actually offer that
and and and of course pay
thank you representative rhodes and then
schmidt
thank you madam
are you able to um specify or give me an
example of the vacancies that you that
you're speaking of are these fuller
part-time positions
um
the
those are full-time positions not the
part-time positions
is is there more one or the other that
that appear to be like the most
vacancies
it would be the full-time positions
right now i mean you have to look at um
excuse me you have to look at seasonal
hires so those ebb and flow based on the
season hiring up for the parks and the
beaches versus
for the ski mountains and things like
that but predominantly it's the
full-time positions that have the most
vacancies yes thank you representative
schmidt
thank you madam chair
so uh i understand at the beginning you
certainly wouldn't want fiscal involved
uh i know you and you for the
flexibility aspect fiscal would also be
very good on a continuing basis but are
they going to be the only
authorizing or
can you put it in the
in the budget
to some degree just
so maybe finance would be involved in
some respects
i i i always envisioned that agencies
would uh request uh budgeting to support
these programs so i i see it as multiple
layers of legislative oversight on on
where is this going and and how is it
being uh mobilized if you will so um i i
no matter what an agency has to have the
money that they could use to
pay this and and the first place you do
that is in budgeting and should an
agency
want to
access this kind of program and not have
it then they have to get transfer
permission within the budget and they
would do that by going to fiscal
committee as well yes
thanks i noticed that this
is uh repealed as of
july 1 2023
so which is the start of the next
biennium's budget
so i presume you're assuming that
whatever you develop in the next
year
will be implemented as necessary in the
next budget and it won't be this
extraordinary program is that correct
yes i also think it was another check
and balance put in place
around the authority and and how is it
um how is the program established how is
it being operationalized and and do they
want to continue
generally speaking when i look at um
this bill if you go back to the first
page and you look at rsa 21i 42 roman 6
it is both a it's a it's a law that
gives the director of the division of
personnel authority and responsibility
to take certain actions and so
i view it as enabling legislation
okay
thank you that's uh that helps
representative bailey
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
can you
are you able to compare your your
recruitment difficulties with those in
the economy at large i mean are you
yes ma'am
[Laughter]
i would say that we have some challenges
when it comes to the market comparing if
we're talking just base salaries that
we're looking at and but we have
excellent benefits and we're really
trying to market those benefits to try
to make up for some of that compensation
but i think we need some flexibility i
think we need some tools on our toolbox
to compete when it's necessary and i'll
give you an example we have agencies
that might have an engineer and they're
both saying oh well i'll give you this
and i'll give you this and i'll give you
this and then this person gets this you
know this say the hundred thousand
dollars that they're getting an offer
for and then they just take it they go
to the outside community and they're
probably getting a hundred and forty
thousand dollars for it so there's gotta
be multiple layers of tools that we can
use we would wanna focus on making sure
that we are looking at the positions
that are most difficult to fill
so it wouldn't be like across the board
okay everybody gets a bonus everybody
gets to do this we also have a lot of
personnel laws where we have to make
sure that there's fairness included in
whatever program that we're developing
we can't leave it up to somebody to get
themselves in trouble saying i like a
and i don't like b and i'm going to do
this for a and not for b so
i think it's important that we just give
ourselves all the tools we can and we
when we need to compete
um we have some departments that are
really low on on some specific jobs that
um are critical i would call them
critical positions so we need to have
some tools to be able to
retain people as well as recruit
thank you does that answer your question
yes thank you thank you very much
representative judy
yes thank you madam chair good afternoon
ma'am
on live 15
uh can you give me more explanation
about uh
your retention incentives please
and based on what
life 15
retention incentives
i think i think the purpose of this is
to make clear that it's not a gift and
um and trigger uh rsa 21g
ethical obligations and i'm sorry i'm
not familiar with specific
provisions right now but it's intended
to make sure that this payment is
representative schuett
thank you madam chair good afternoon
ladies
i am curious to know the nature of
the vacancies are you finding that these
are just
literally long-term not filled
or have there been situations where
a number of people have been employed
but then are dissatisfied with
whatever the the reason work or our
well i can give you a little bit
information and we are breaking down um
when somebody leaves state government
one of the things that we're trying to
build in now is exit surveys why are you
leaving what is the reason
right now they currently have if you're
if you're looking at a chat okay
there's a large section that says
personal well personal doesn't tell us
anything so we're working with our
financial data management um folks to
get in there is it because specifically
because of pay are you leaving the state
are you is it benefits you know is it a
bad working environment is it a
supervisor so um we'll be able to drill
down and get you more information in the
future
follow up
so do you have
any kind of projection as to when this
kind of data might be available
um i would say we would probably
probably july somewhere around july we
would be able to have it up and running
and then it would take each quarter we
could come back and
be able to deliver that information
thank you representative fellows you had
a question
thank you madam chair um
i know that
currently
you have some special incentives
they're probably related to kobit for
some positions
is that correct
i think they both or bonuses oh okay but
they were
so my question is
how how did that operate and are you
thinking of
um modeling
this program
along the same line as that one did so
do you identify particular you don't
identify in individuals that they have
to go back to fiscal to get approved i
assume it's like some class of um i
agree i think what they're looking for
us is a program and what maybe potential
costs are probably fiscal no going with
it to say you know what do you think
this would cost
i'm imagining is that um yeah i also do
see us targeting um types of positions
that are particularly hard to recruit so
um i think that might be where you were
getting at
i wish i could think of a question i
just want to say good luck
thank you
representative pearson
thank you man of chair
so this is going to tie into a couple of
other things that were said
we
with the jcec right we have it we
that are similar amongst agencies right
together
okay tip step and grade government
government pay it's everywhere right
so
how
you're going to have to and i i don't
know if you can answer this now but
you're going to have to figure out a way
where you have a very specific one of
those
step and grade jobs right to move it
either move the grade
or
because what's going to end up you know
what i what jc easy was
created to do was to level the playing
field
and i'm
concerned that this
will completely untie that knot
you know in the sense of
not specific individuals like
representative fellows would seem to
address but when we're looking at
reclassification
of
certain job types
that would that may be an answer to your
to what the you guys come up with
i'm just trying to i'm just trying to
can you senator d'alessandro couldn't
answer it but
this is not a committee or a commission
so when you're talking about a broad
spectrum of
across the board government
um i'm confused and please help us out
here on because you mentioned on page
two line four the repeal of this
that
seems there's a repeal for
this
one or i-426
this rewrites i are you just
i don't understand this repeal business
okay
so do you feel you can accomplish this
um i do believe that
we will get something up and running in
the nature of a pilot and we will have
data that will allow
the legislature to decide oh this was a
good idea it worked
this wasn't enough time to prove the
idea or disprove it or it turns out it
wasn't a great idea and we want it to to
go away um
so so
pardon i'm just
concerned that that the timeline is too
aggressive well if you would like to
extend it you're you're not going to
hear any opposition
thank you
if you're aware government moves at the
speed of smell right so
a year in the real world in government
is not the same and that's
right
we
helpful to us i would expect that if
nothing else this would be inclu
any successful parts of this would be
included in the budget
i hope so too
yes they would have to be yes and i had
uh this obviously is going to affect
negotiations with the employees unions
is
uh what
how what are you doing about that or is
that a concern or what so so um there is
a paragraph of this that says it's
specifically outside of um
collective bargaining i'm looking for
the language now so oh it's paragraph d
on line 24 beginning on line 24.
um
[Music]
i actually think that the unions will
welcome this legislatively authorized
program because i think what we do with
a recruitment and retention incentive
plan is we we mobilize our workforce and
ask them to help us
i'll let laurie talk about the best way
to recruit people uh and um it turns out
it's it's all around us but go ahead
sure um i'll just talk about um a
program that i had in my former position
so it was called say we were looking at
getting um highway maintainers
and that was going to be an area that we
were going to focus on what would do is
we'd have a referral bonus so that way
the employee's getting something after a
period of time and the new um the new
employee and the
employee that referred them
so um those are the type of programs
that you would say okay i'm gonna go out
and recruit some of my buddies because
i'm gonna i have a little incentive in
this myself to earn some bonus money so
i'm gonna you know be out there talking
to people that word of mouth and you're
already working for the state is very
popular because you can speak to all the
benefits and what we have and what the
hours may be and to different
opportunities throughout
you know state government so that's an
example of something that we would use
it for okay thank you representative
blackish you had a question oh yes thank
you so um
assuming this passes and you end up
finding some things that work
for this to continue beyond
july of 2023
would it require an addition to
something in the budget would it require
legislation to extend or make permanent
some of the things in here
it would require a change of the date
and um i i think if this passes that we
will begin working on two fronts one is
we will be working on the design of the
program what would we want to present to
fiscal committee for approval the other
thing is we would begin working with
agencies to educate them about the
passage of this law so they could
consider the kinds of vacancies that
they have and and whether and to what
extent they might want to propose
funding in their budgets
for for the next biennium
follow-up follow-up so if i understand
correctly um
for this for anything to continue beyond
july 2023
you'll have to come back and ask for
some legislative change
yes unless this committee amends the
bill uh well eventually you can't yes
thank you thank you good job
representative pearson you have a
follow-up i have a question for the
chair i'm just trying to do i'm just
looking at the calendar here right so
we're going to start working on the next
the legislature will start working on
the next budget in the fall of 22.
so your timeline of july of 23
is is
it doesn't really fall in line with the
legislative calendar it it gives us
fiscal year 23 to get this up and
running and
because you're not going to we're you
know you're talking if you were to do
that in july you know the fall of 23
you're talking about amending an enacted
budget
right so this really could go you this
date of july of 23 could be pushed out
to december
of 23 and have really no substantive
effect on what you would recommend
on in the budget cycle because the next
budget cycle would be fall of 24. so so
the next budget and forgive me if i get
the dates wrong but but the legislature
comes back in january of 23 and that's a
budget year and the budget is debated
from
january through june right the filing
period would be the fall of 22. right so
so what you are saying that's correct is
all agency budgets for next fiscal year
are already decided right so if an
agency
if we have approval from fiscal
and an agency wants to seek authority to
pay a recruitment or a retention
incentive bonus i i think most agencies
are going to have to go to fiscal and
ask to transfer money as well as
permission to
um pay a bonus for certain positions and
also they would include it in their
budget going forward for that absolutely
okay and then and they would include it
yes it's very tightly in their proposed
budgets it's very very tight
um
we think it's worth it we think it's a
very important tool in the toolkit
okay thank you we will
we will continue to be concerned about
your performance on the schedule
which which of you has a question
representative fellows thank you i
wasn't sure
thank you
um
so when this gets repealed in in july of
right now you have the authority
for developing a program of recruitment
selection
of qualified applicants why do you even
need this why can't you just operate
i personally don't think we have
authority to pay
incentive bonuses for recruitment or
retention purposes and so so um that's
why we
we asked for the legislation to be
proposed
this authority that you see in existing
law i think it's again
a law that establishes the director of
personnel's
responsibilities and authorities um but
none of it
none of that authorities is explicitly
empowers her to have a paid recruitment
or
uh retention she needs the legislation
to put money into it instead of just add
a boys and certificates yes
which are valuable but not not not
always as useful
you'll follow up
so
i thought that you had been doing this
were you using federal money and so
that's why it's different was different
than what you're proposing now
i'm not sure what are you talking about
like when the liquor stores got a 10
increase no she's talking about the
covid and emergency bonuses and
retention programs which were federal
and they were also limited in time to
the emergency yes
exactly so
wasn't that
under this authority to use
to use that no no it was under um an
okay
thank you are there other questions
represent allegro
thank you so
that's an interesting point
um you've had a trial period with
federal dollars
i'll speak to it i'll try to speak to it
thank you um
what i think happened with that was we
didn't have we had people who could have
chosen to
not work any longer due to covid and
that we would have had a crisis on our
hands if we didn't give some incentives
i would say it was used more as like a
hazard pay would be used saying you're
at risk and you're out inside of these
environments and we're going to
recognize that risk as we do we do have
um hazard pay that happens in other
areas so um i think it was more used to
that than really understanding how do we
recruit and retain people
so
this this is actually i think a question
for the chair and that is uh sort of
understanding
what this language does on the repeal so
right now there's something in 21i42
roman 6
and this bill would replace it and then
after july 2023 it would it looks like
it repeals
rsa21i426 as it does it revert to the
thank you madam chair
this kind of piggies back with my
original question and then some of the
other questions and i apologize if this
was answered because i'm still trying to
figure it out from other questions
are you able to
what area
would you say are you having the most
difficulty is there like a certain area
where you you look at your departments
and say
this like this is the department
that we just can't keep jobs filled
thank you that's what i wanted
yeah we could talk corrections we could
talk nurses we could talk
child support
workers
um we have enforcement in health care
and in other areas um child protection
yeah child protection workers we have
you know
engineers we have a tough we are um
we're getting out competed by the market
in um technology um so it's um highway
maintainers in in das we have um a
series of positions called building
service workers they clean state
buildings
we have a 50 percent vacancy rate in
those positions
it's just really really difficult to
recruit people
and to
thank you
other questions representative fellows
one question please
thank you madam chair
so it seems to me that part of the most
of the problem is probably that we just
don't pay enough you know we don't have
competitive wages
so i'm i'm
thinking that
you know this recruitment and retention
bonus thing and for just a year or two
is not going to solve the problem and
also i know with the
on your classified employees you use
that firm that does an analysis of of
what the
what
the positions and what the pay grade
ought to be when was the last time we
did something like that for the
classified employees positions
so
i'll ask lori to help me out a little
but um when representative pearson was
discussing the jcec and the process that
we use with corn ferry we our classified
positions are part of a classified um
system and we do that same
sort of comparison of position types
across state government for all
classified positions in a unit in the
division of personnel okay
so
so we do
look at
if if i'm
i'm coming up dry with an example but if
i if i do this job in this department
and same job in this department and same
job in that department
there are similar job functions and
therefore those positions are ranked
similarly
also
we just when did you let's do that um
well as a matter of fact we we do it um
fairly okay i'll let laurie's talk yeah
so we're doing this almost daily right
we have four people
we have four people represent our
you like
when you did it for the unclassified
that you were comparing it
not just within state government you
were comparing it to other
similar positions outside of our state
government but i distinctly heard you
say
that you answered me by saying you can
you were comparing positions
across the state i'm asking when is the
last time for classified you made a
comparison to
you know
outside of state government or compared
to other state governments and i
understand benefits are different but
you can do a calculation that kind of
adjusts for that i assume
and i won't ask another question as long
as they answer my question so there's a
difference between ranking positions and
pay and we did just do a compensation
study and i'll let laurie speak to how
we do the ranking of positions and then
we'll we'll tell you about our
compensation study
i think the question was compensation
okay
yeah i think um cassie's going to speak
to the fact we did two years ago um we
um received the authority or or we were
asked to
do a compensation study we picked 100
positions
all across the agencies all different
levels of the agencies
that report is posted on our website now
that you could take a look at if you
wanted to
but two years a lot of things have
changed right so um we've come into
covert we a lot of things have happened
that have made the market a different
place than it was two years ago
as far as the internal ranking that's
happening every day
and you don't care about that okay
thank you very much did that answer your
question representative
i'm sure i'm sure you have a lot of
issues with this any other questions
all right thank you very much for the
information
good afternoon thank you um hope you
don't mind if
commissioner hanks joins me to answer
any questions that you may have
uh good afternoon my name is paul
raymond i'm the director of security
and training for the new hampshire
department of corrections
and you all know commissioner hanks
who's here with me and we are here
testifying in favor of senate bill 226.
recruitment and retention is the
department's number one priority in the
last few
few months we have streamlined our
hiring processes unveiled a dedicated
jobs website and initiated statewide
radio and social media recruiting
campaigns those initiatives while
helpful are still competing with
organizations like the federal bureau of
prisons that is offering an eleven
thousand dollar sign-on bonus at their
berlin new hampshire facility
locally even police departments like
pelham rochester bedford and concord are
offering sign-on bonuses up to fifteen
thousand dollars
elsewhere in the country states like
alabama florida south carolina delaware
iowa virginia and nebraska have
increased pay for corrections officers
and many have added new higher bonuses
to their recruitment efforts iowa as an
example increased pay and added hiring
bonuses and have seen a 15 percent
increase in qualified applicants
the department of corrections currently
has a 34 percent department-wide vacancy
rate among its security staff a 16
vacancy rate among its nurses and a 50
vacancy rate among
mental health clinicians
that equates to poor work-life balance
for our team and significant overtime to
fill positions to meet our minimum
standard for shifts
corrections work is challenging work
and it's even more challenging to find
the right person not any person but the
right person to work inside the walls of
a prison allowing the state to offer
recruitment and retention incentives
including bonuses and referral fees is
one positive step toward helping our
department attract the right people i
respectfully ask that you support senate
bill 226 thank you and we're happy to
representative pearson
thank you mr raymond thank you
commissioner
34 is pretty staggering so it
in the course of your budget
how fast do you expend your overtime
line
your yearly over how quick do you use
that up
representative pearson thank you for
that question
we expend the budgeted line
in approximately one quarter in one
month and we have a budget foot yep
we've spent about three million dollars
a quarter in overtime
we budget about 4 million in that line
there is a budget footnote that allows
us to move money from our
funded position lines and benefits lines
that are result of vacancies to fund the
overtime that's caused from those
vacancies so we use our own internal
budgeting
lines but we have a transferring
mechanism last year we spent
approximately 16 million dollars in
overtime
and we're forecasting about the same
this year because of the number of
retirements we had in december and
poor retention efforts going on
currently in the work environment
yes thank you
other questions
all right
seeing none thank you very much for the
information
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on senate bill 226
all right seeing none i will close the
hearing
open the hearing on senate bill 225 and
thank you madam chair
good afternoon to you and the entire
committee
for the record my name is harold french
i'm senator for district seven
and i'm here today to present to you
senate bill 225.
this is a
short bill
so this bill will eliminate the need for
a new hampshire licensed auctioneer to
carry a 25 000 performance bond
i personally been a licensed auctioneer
in this state since i was 18.
i became an auctioneer when i was a
senior in high school
i grew up in the industry and has
changed drastically since the 1970s
until the advent of the internet a
hundred percent of all goods sold at
auction
were sold live and in person
all were conducted by licensed
auctioneers
today perhaps two percent of goods sold
at auction in new hampshire are sold
live
with the majority being sold on the
internet
this state does not require licensing
for those conducting auctions online as
it was determined to be impossible for
the state to regulate interstate
commerce when dealing with online
auctions
since the start of licensing auctioneers
had the requirement of maintaining a
performance bond
there has never been an instance where
the bond was used to settle a dispute
among the parties
this bill would update our licensing
laws making them more reasonable for the
way businesses conducted today
in eliminating an unneeded expense in
hurdle for those wishing to pursue
their business goals of auctioneering
thank you madam chair
pearson thank you thank you senator
french just
just so i have clarification you're
saying that
the bond the 25 000 bond that an
auctioneer has to have has never been
never been needed
to your knowledge ever to sell the
dispute no
okay okay thank you that's
yes any other questions
good
thank you very much thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
all right seeing none i'll close the
public hearing
and open the
senate bill is senator khan here
yes
hello madam chair
uh members of the committee
uh
i'm pleased to
offer
the bill
[Music]
is a fairly
simple and straightforward
might be uh
having been
complicated somewhere along the way i
but
um
we've had a temporary licensure
requirement
emergency order
and the emergency order ended
at december 31st
and that temporary order allowed uh
out-of-state
physicians to
practice in the state of new hampshire
uh
about
that there were many
licenses involved in that then you've
got
professional licensure and certification
here they can answer that question but i
believe the number is somewhere around
22 000
000 contemporary licensures thank you we
have that we've gotten that information
on many other occasions okay
significant is that
there are several pieces of legislation
attempting to clarify the process of
moving
from temporary licensure status
to
permanent or continuing licensure
one of which is senate bill 277 and
maybe that's one madam chair that you've
already heard that extends that
temporary licensure date
got it
and
so the reason why to pass on this bill
one
is we
want to provide the same
quality assurances
for
for people receiving
care from people in state as they
receive out of state
this kind of quality control is assured
with a licensure provision
a person who is licensed out of state
will present that license
it's easy to do those kinds of
background checks on people
those quality controls are important for
patient safety and health
the second is that that's important for
insurance coverage
uh insurers are going to be looking for
uh have has that kind of uh
quality assurance been verified by our
so that's uh important to make sure that
people are getting the reimbursements
that they deserve for the care that
they're seeking
uh
uh finally uh
you know that we need a transition
for those folks that uh continue to use
the temporary licensure route uh beyond
january of 2024
to be able to transition
to a permanent licensure and this
the
new section that was added in section
two 2
the state will seek reciprocity
agreements with those that are not in
the physician compact
that compact covers 31 states
uh
and so
trying to to reach to those that might
not be in that compact currently
and that's the
nature of the bill
and uh because
director lindsey
courtney is here i i think a remainder
of questions probably most efficiently
asked of her
but
thank you senator we'll probably will
grill you a little first i think
i have a question what is the
consultation services
referred to in line seven
um that would be
uh
where a
in-state physician is consulting with an
out-of-state physician on a particular
type of care or modality of treatment so
that's a physician-to-physician
consultation and not patient to
physician that's correct thank you very
much are there any other questions
thank you madam cure
good afternoon senator uh so has it been
either has it been resolved
established or ju by adjudication or
whatever
i know the mayfair decision came down a
couple years ago
whether a service that's provided
by telehealth
is
is being
performed
in the state of the recipient or the
state of the provider or maybe even both
what is the state status status of the
law
right at the moment with regard to that
issue
i'm going to let
the director
answer that because i think they're
you're picking up on the variety the
variations on
delivery uh if a person is in state i
mean this is this is particular to an
in-state
uh person seeking care in-state
and then there are all sorts of
variations off of that
yeah you probably everything follow up
thank you you probably have seen some of
them yourself i certainly have received
a bunch of emails
talking about please kill 282 because
sorry 382 because uh we want the freedom
blah blah blah blah but the question is
you know
what is the law with regard to
and there again there are very many
variations if a person is deployed out
of state and has out-of-state insurance
coverage uh for that the person is going
to seek the
the care from a person in whatever state
that their they have their insurance
coverage
uh provided for
uh
but again i i i'll let that
there are a lot of i understand your
reluctance to just a lot of variations
on that question
other questions for the center
all right seeing none thank you very
much thank you
good afternoon lindsay courtney
executive director oplc
oplc is pleased to testify in support of
senate bill 382
which
is really intended
to clarify the existing state of the law
in new hampshire which is that in order
to practice in this state and the
provision of services is deemed to occur
in the state where the patient is
located that you need a license
um
and i think that is is not explicitly
clear because it's not set forth in
statute but it's been interpreted i
think by regulators as well as other
states
to to be that way and the reason for
that is
twofold first the state obviously has an
interest in protecting the people within
its state
um if a person is in new hampshire we
have an interest in protecting the
person in new hampshire we probably
don't have the same interest in
protecting somebody in you know alabama
um
but also um our jurisdictionally right
our our ability our jurisdiction only
extends uh to new hampshire so when
given the choice of does our jerks
jurisdiction extend to where the
provider is located or does it extend to
where the patient is located
um public policy probably dictates that
the jurisdiction really is uh governed
by where the patient is located because
the purpose of licensing is to protect
the public
so um throughout the pandemic obviously
as you know telehealth essentially
exploded overnight and and um you know
the platform grew immensely
and we started to field a lot of
questions about do i need a license for
this do i need a license for that um
it's not typically with within our
practice based on legal advice from doj
to provide such legal advice right do
you need a license
we point people to the statute and the
rules and the statute and rules say well
if you're practicing medicine in new
hampshire you need a license in new
hampshire but it doesn't explicitly
state what constitutes practice in new
hampshire and so that's what this is
intended to cover
the other issue this addresses is choice
of law
the only other
association group of
a group of associations that i'm aware
of that have taken an alternative
position
to
to the idea that the provision of
services occurs where the patient is
located
is a couple of the social work or mental
health associations nationally have
taken the position that
that the service occurs where both the
provider and the patient is located
that really makes no sense
because the laws differ in each state so
for example
in new hampshire the duty to warn may be
different than in massachusetts
so if the provider is in new hampshire
but the patient is in massachusetts
which law do they have to follow
there there really should only be one
that they have to follow and i would
submit that it should be
massachusetts because that's where the
patient is located and massachusetts has
an interest in protecting that patient
so again this was intended to clarify
the existing state of the law
which has always been that if you're
practicing
or providing services in new hampshire
to somebody located in new hampshire
that you need a license
um there were concerns i think based on
confusion in the stakeholder community
that uh
that this statute would essentially
eliminate the ability to seek providers
elsewhere
um and that from my perspective is not
um not the case
however um
based on those concerns you know i think
what we largely heard was that there was
a concern that providers needing
licensure could not obtain licensure
easily and so particularly for
physicians and so section two is
intended to address that by allowing the
state to enter into reciprocity
agreements to streamline that process
we do have a medicine compact so
physician compact
and again 31 states are participating i
would not say it's the best compact
you know it's not like the nursing
compact or the driver's license compact
that you can just go wherever
it does require one to apply to the
federation of state medical boards
to process their credentials and right
now there's an eight to twelve week
backlog
i will say that this would allow us to
enter into separate agreements with
states
to streamline the process
and additionally
we already have existing ability to
issue temporary licenses to people who
are pursuing permanent licensure so
um there certainly is an opportunity for
people to obtain license in a in a fast
time frame
um with that i'd be happy to answer any
questions that the committee may have
my goodness
representative allegro
lekkis martian pearson in alphabetical
order
thank you i'll ask my question by way of
example so that it
can lead us to a yes or no answer
say a patient lives in massachusetts
they're physicians in massachusetts they
move to new hampshire
they can't find a suitable or acceptable
physician in new hampshire that does the
same thing maybe it's a specialist
so they go back to their massachusetts
physician
and indeed that physician even
prescribes a medication for them
which is delivered to a new hampshire
pharmacy
and insurance covers that prescription
will that be allowable under
this current bill or this law
the question will depend on where did
the consul where did the patient visit
occur
um if the person went down to boston
like i do i get all my specialist
treatment in boston um
then certainly the provider was
practicing medicine in massachusetts
massachusetts law is governed
they absolutely can do that this bill
has no impact on that
and they can certainly
dispense to a new hampshire pharmacy
follow-up
so let's i'm gonna complicate it a
little bit and say it's
there was no visit no subsequent visit
but the patient is on an ongoing
prescription so they haven't visited
that physician now in massachusetts
since they changed their residence to
new hampshire
but
they need that prescription the
physician
supplies the prescription and it's
picked up in new hampshire is that
allowable
yes because that there was no
service
occurring between the physician and it's
based on a first of all there's an
exemption in the medical statute for the
medicine statute
for those types of consultations across
border and then secondly i would submit
that that's not
providing a service it's certainly
continuing to authorize prescriptions
but as you know
and i know representative marsh knows
that physicians will call you back often
for a visit saying i can't authorize any
more
prescriptions based on prior
examinations without submitting to
another examination so the question
would be
you know in a follow-up service how does
that occur and i will also say that this
issue came up during the pandemic the
reason why we issued 22 000 health care
licenses was because 15 000 of them were
boston providers who were new hampshire
medicaid enrolled
providers and our patients could not go
to boston hospitals to receive the
services in massachusetts they didn't
typically need a new hampshire license
because they were physically going there
and when the blossom providers moved to
a telehealth platform they were deemed
to be practicing in new hampshire which
is why we needed to issue all of those
licenses so that those services could
continue so it it does it is the state
of it is the existing state of the law
there would be no change in the existing
uh thank you you this gets to the
question of
interpretation of the law
as to whether
you know someone resides in new
hampshire and they consult through
telemedicine
you know is it clear that that doctor
must be licensed in new hampshire and my
question you said there would be
you gave some justification for a
particular interpretation what i'm
asking is has there been any case law
either in new hampshire
first or if not new hampshire elsewhere
addressing that question that you know
of i'm not aware of any case law in new
hampshire addressing that issue i am
aware of case law elsewhere um
i obviously don't have citations off the
top of my head and i could certainly
provide that information to you i would
say that it's implicit not explicit in
the existing statutory framework because
the for example the physician practice
act speaks to requirements for licensure
that you need a license
to do x y and z in new hampshire it's
implied right because the state can only
regulate what's in their
what's within their border and then it
carves out exemptions
exemptions being consultation services
which implies that you know maybe the
service is actually occurring in new
hampshire but we're going to carve out
this exemption
also carves out an exemption for if you
have an established physician-patient
relationship
um it carves out that
exemption and you're on the border
so the fact that the legislature felt
the need to carve out exemptions to me
suggests
from a statutory standpoint that
certainly this is the case
yeah i mean i understand
that i mean that's your interpretation
i'm not saying it's whether it's
reasonable or not um just uh if you
could send me anything where there's
actually you know been uh judicial
opinions on that i appreciate sure
absolutely representative
representative marsh
thank you madam chair and thank you
director courtney for taking my question
my question relates to the consultation
exemption on line seven and i'm asking
this question in the context of being
the chair of the rare disease advisory
council where that exemption comes into
play
there may be some
certain physicians who may be one in the
country say in los angeles who knows a
particular disease my understanding of
that exemption is that the the 329 21 2
exemption allows my rare disease patient
to be seen in a telemedicine servicing
consultation with the rare disease
specialist who is for instance in
california
as long as that
patient also has a physician in the
state of new hampshire who actually
writes the orders for whatever treatment
is decided by is that correct yes that's
thank you madam chair
i have i kinda i guess i have two
questions
this
first of all
outside of a compact we're looking at
some folks in some other states
is there
any state in new england that is not in
that the compact that we're in
off the top of my head representative i
don't know for medicine
okay i can get that information too
okay so then
my second my second question
this this amends 310 a1g house senate
bill 277 amends 310 a1i and f
or
do you
do these have to exist together i mean i
i i know that one of them involves the
temporary the emergency licenses that
were issued under coven and whether or
not we're going to extend those out to
and this one's
along the lines of continuing to do some
covet type of things we did but it isn't
and it is in reference to licensing
otherwise this committee wouldn't have
it but
do you see a tie-in between
382 and 277
um to some extent i think the reason why
we drafted as creating a new section
was so that it there wouldn't be
conflicts when the bills are enrolled
because we saw that last session um so
i've learned my lesson with that
um
but i think overall portability is a
huge problem and we'll talk about that
at 3 30. uh these are really band-aids
and like 277's a band-aid
um i think the state we really need to
figure this out um and have one cohesive
solution or two uh to the problem of
portability because new hampshire is not
we're not home growing our workforce so
we're attracting it from other states
and
i think our licensure needs to
recognize that portability is is going
to impact our ability to meet our
workforce demands so i view it as a
band-aid i don't think there's a
conflict because of the way that it's
written
um but i'm hopeful that uh that over the
next
session we'll be able to to make some
decisions
other questions
represent marsh
i just wanted to answer the question
about the interstate medical licensure
compact because this is something we
dealt with in hhs it's my understanding
that the state of massachusetts does not
participate in that compact although
they just introduced legislation in
march to do something
that's kind of disconcerting since
and it makes sense because they
historically have not joined compacts
in that case i certainly hope you get a
a reciprocity agreement very very
quickly although i understand they're
not excited about those either right
okay um i do have one question i've
heard
numerous advertisements for ver for uh
various websites and so forth that say
you
just call us log on the doctor will talk
to you and we'll give you a prescription
for viagra
that's the most common one yes
no i've heard the ads my question is are
those
websites and programs practicing
medicine illegally
i would think if they're not licensed
then yes
if there's a new hampshire patient
and we saw that with cannabis right
during the emergency order we there are
a lot of
shops that
popped open
specifically to
approve
cannabis for new hampshire patients but
if yeah if they were not
if they're not licensed here then i
would think that that would be
thank you i thought that was the case
but it
but i'm not a lawyer any other questions
representative allegro
just my general edification how is that
enforced for instance if somebody orders
a viagra from seven states away
so that's part of the problem and that's
another reason why we want to clarify
that
that the service occurs where the
patient is located because often you're
in an investigation or disciplinary
action your witnesses are going to be
here
um
the person complaining should be able to
complain to the local medical board
but uh
that
the enforcement mechanism it depends on
the board
most of them have no enforcement
mechanism other than to refer it over to
the department of justice and the
consumer protection bureau
for potential criminal and civil action
we in the last budget cycle um
and
we we changed the way we
work with doj in that sense and that
we're fully funding their
two positions and consumers specifically
dedicated to unlicensed practice because
medicine does have the capability to
fine people for unlicensed practice
but
it's hit or miss whether we collect and
whether it actually prevents people from
you know
thank you are there any other questions
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
so in the last bill and i think you were
still well are you already here for that
we heard a lot about
um
low numbers of employees in
a number of agencies and ways of trying
to get at that but this strikes me as as
being something that is maybe
as bad or worse
with regard to all this interstate stuff
and tele whatever
telemedicine especially
are we as bad off
and
because it looks to me like we're kind
of heading for a cliff where thing
things break down in terms of the
ability you already talked about
enforcement and so forth so you can
speak to that
so if they're licensed here we can take
action so that's why we prefer them to
be licensed because if we take action on
their license we have obligations to
report it to the national practitioner
data bank and if it's other professions
other reporting and then if they try to
get licensed elsewhere or if the public
wants to look them up they can see it's
completely transparent
the unlicensed practice is problematic
because
because it lacks that
level of transparency but the generally
a licensing board's jurisdiction only
extends over their licensees it probably
should be the case right which is why we
refer to doj
was your question more about the
workforce are we do we have workforce
issues or is it more about enforcement
as we roll out uh continue to roll out
telehealth
well enforcement is obviously a very
important aspect because to the degree
you get some kind of an order
because somebody's doing something
illegal and they say
basically
piss off
uh
yeah
that's a very bad situation because that
on the it with the internet that's going
to get around
nationwide worldwide
and
so then it grows like topsy
so
yeah the international stuff is more
difficult with interstate practice
it's a little bit easier so for example
if
we caught wind that somebody was
practicing without a license but they
were licensed elsewhere
we would typically report it to that
licensure board wherever they're
licensed because they may they probably
have a catch-all clause that says you
know
agree to practice ethically which it's
probably not ethical to
you know illegally practice
um so that's why it's the people who
are not licensed in another state and
are just doing things um
those are the ones that i think are most
difficult um but doj has pursued uh you
know criminal and civil actions against
those individuals you know after
investigation so
thank you uh so
i know we in the past we've had big
problems with
pill mills in florida for example but
i'm sure it's not the only state or
maybe not even the worst state anymore
because
everything is expanding so crazily
whether it's
an opening is like water goes wherever
the opening is
yeah so i think the question with
respect to the bill has to be whether or
not the state has requirements that are
substantially equivalent or exceed our
um
our
requirements and the idea of a compact
or reciprocity agreement really is based
on trust of the other state we're
trusting the other state first of all
they have the requirements in place that
are like ours and we're trusting the
other state to vet them
um
you know maybe we don't want to trust
the other state to vet them and then we
don't have any compacts in any
agreements but then it takes longer for
our people to get licensed which could
impact workforce so those are the type
of policy
um
things that you know the state needs to
consider
i've i support compacts because i think
it uh
first of all it recognizes the state's
right to regulate people within its
borders and um
and to determine the requirements
um ours may not be the same so if if
they're not the same we don't enter into
a compact
um
and it allows us to
to promote or to allow workforce
given the fact that we are un under
duress in terms of uh timeline and all
this other kind of stuff
is is it
your opinion as oplc director that this
is something that we can and should do
right now
i i think so i think that
there needs to be clarity um although
i think it's clear i'm an attorney so uh
you know it's not clear because we get
calls with us every day
and uh
i think it would be nice to be able to
point them to a statute saying this is
i have a question you said that there is
an exemption
how what kind of an exemption is that
how long does it go for so
i believe the exemption on that that one
is if you're traveling so let's say
somebody in florida is traveling
and they're here temporarily i think the
statute uses the term temporarily in the
state
they can
still consult with their position but
down in florida and donate a license
and then there's also an exemption for
cross-border practice so if you're
if you're somebody who practices on the
border let's say with massachusetts and
the patient lives over the border
there's an exception for that as well
thank you
other questions
okay
thank you thank you for joining us thank
you all right is there any anyone else
all right seeing none i will close the
and we have 12 minutes before the next
one
okay
welcome back
this is a public hearing on a
non-germane amendment
to
senate bill 330
the
the notice was a little confusing
because it repeated everything the bill
did
the non-germane part on which we are
going to concentrate
is the oplc oversight committee which
representative schuett will be
presenting
thank you madam chair
for the record i am representative diane
schuett
i represent merrimack 20 the towns of
pembroke and chichester
um
the original amendment that you folks
had
i believe everyone on the committee got
a copy
of amendment 14 24
which is what the
hearing today is advertised for
and
i will say
that
let me just be sure what i'm looking at
here
yeah
the new section starts on page 2 line 14
right and and it addressed the original
committee that was in
senate bill 330
as it was introduced
senator gaida as the prime sponsor
and our chair as one of the co-sponsors
at the suggestion
of our chair
i added
the
portions of
the study that we killed from senate
bill 313
that addressed funding
part of the funding issues for oplc
that was added into
this amendment
rather than create two separate studies
just have the study that was in this
bill
then um
if you look
on page 2
beginning page line 16
[Music]
again with
some oversight from our chair
i worked on the language to create an
oversight committee
to
try and examine some of the issues that
we've heard
between
interactions of various boards
commissions
councils
and the administration portion of oplc
and hopefully
an oversight committee
somewhat
like the oversight committee for health
and human services
would be able to hear some of these
concerns
suggest
remedies and
hopefully smooth things out
so that the operation
of all the boards and commissions
is a little more smooth
other than that if i can answer any
questions i will try
representative
thank you um
at least initially just one on the new
section um line 32 on page two
um and it's saying you know who all
should be um
to bring things the attention i would
suggest
given that the whole purpose of
occupational licensing is at least
nominally to protect the public
that it should have said and members of
should i don't see it in there
um
and that's
then a follow-up if i could
a lot yeah at uh
at some point i'd like an explanation of
um
of
the part dealing with the repeals and
the interaction with the original bill
and the wrestling commission and all
that thank you
um i
i will answer the second part of your
question first
i did include language talking about
appeals
however the uh drafting attorney
objected to that language stating that
appeals are something that need to be
adjudicated by courts the repeals the
i'm sorry which where uh page three
starting line uh three
and how that what you know what would
the the whole bill look like if we
adopted this that's all
uh you know what
i think i have a bad copy of myself
about this the repealing repealing of
well i'm not sure that's what i'm
we're looking at this thing
is it this one
why don't i have a good copy of this
amendment
thank you
sorry
now then i'm sorry uh line three did you
say
no this is not a rewrite amendment for
those who are trying to follow along it
only affects the sections of the bill
that we are
under that are being changed section two
is ch which is the study committee that
is changed by the addition of duties
from a
different study committee that we're
combining with the funding
portion from 313 correct and then all
after section 9 we're adding a new
a new oversight committee which is brand
new language section 3 through eight are
unchanged by this bill
we
representative schumer also has an
amendment that also deletes the boxing
and wrestling commission change
that but there's a second amendment to
330.
outside of four one four two whatever
this is four two five this the part of
this amendment that is totally new and
that we were recommended to hold a
non-germain
amendment hearing on
is
okay thank you sorry for the
interruption but please proceed
representative thank you i appreciate
the assistance i
unfortunately
i had
a different draft of the amendment i'm
not sure how that happened but
we went through a couple different
iterations trying to craft the language
and it it's true the the rest of the
bill
was not my intention to be affected just
adding the funding to the original study
and then the oversight committee
and i leave it to the
committee members if they feel
somehow the public should be included
in some of that language
the
i'm not sure
perhaps
director courtney can answer if
i don't know if the public is actually
involved
in interactions of oplc and their boards
and councils
the boards have public members
and most of the complaints come from the
public
okay
are there other questions representative
um schmidt
so i'm wondering i mean i i hear where
you're coming from tony with regard to
the idea that a member of the public
maybe should be involved the problem is
that even in this committee where we
deal with
all these things to some degree on a
regular basis
or have in the past
just
overwhelmed with all the various
different aspects that he or she might
have to be involved in and they
might or might not be more trouble than
they're worth
uh in terms of being able to be helpful
um
even if i like the idea of maybe getting
some kind of a genius uh that could help
um
i'm not sure we have any geniuses that
want to take this on
do you have a question representative
well the first question i have is just
since representative schuett says she
has a funky copy are we all looking at
1424 h
yes i have the correct
representative grota found the correct
copy for me
and i will point out that
the original study
requested in 3 30
is designed to report by i believe it's
november 1st
of this year and the oversight committee
is to take effect
january 1st of 2023
to be able to perhaps utilize
whatever the
study originally in 330 may come up with
as
suggestions or things to be looked at
representative lekis thank you i just
wanted to clarify the question i was
asking um
and it was on
the section three line of page two line
thirty two
i was asking if you consider adding
members of the public to the list not as
a member of the committee
but as um
you know the group of people that might
um
bring issues to the attention
it says as brought to its attention by
the office personnel legislators it goes
on and i was just wondering if there was
a reason why members of the public was
not included in that list not membership
okay representative
i would just say that
as with health and human services
oversight committee members of the
public obviously can
attend listen and hear the
reasonings what have you for
whatever interactions they're examining
they also examine
interactions between health care
providers
and the agencies of the state
just a brief follow-up if i may
yeah i i know it's a public hearing and
they could attend but my question was
that they could be people would be
recognized as people who could bring
issues before the committee that was
representative grota
thank you madam chair so i'm
representative schuett
i have my my concern
is that
you're
am i understanding this correctly that
this oversight committee
would not sunset would just be permanent
now there is
a sunset provision
part of the repeal
that you see um line five
the oversight committee
is due to sunset
and it's
under the effective date paragraph 2
sun sets january 1st of 2028
so it would have a five-year life span
and if
the oversight committee determines that
there is enough reason to continue
the legislature could choose to do that
but right now it's built in with a five
follow-up
so the oversight committee would run
the study committee and the
oversight committee would run in tandem
are they the same people no no i believe
the
we need to add a repeal of the study
committee after it issues its final
report in november of 2020 okay that's
my confusion that would be the
appropriate way to do it okay thank you
yeah as i stated that's why
we made the effective date of the
oversight committee january of 2023
because the study committee technically
is supposed to do
a report on november 2022
and then a final report november of 2023
but if the oversight committee has
issues
that were put forward by the report on
november
2022 they could begin looking at those
issues
if we were to take representatives
lucas's of um suggestion to include
would that not cause confusion as to
what the lines of communications are
because
is the public now
not going to
oplc with their complaints and this this
ca if i understand correctly
this oversight committee is just to
discuss the issues between the board
and the director it's not
the function of the oplc is that correct
okay
that's my intent
yes we
you may have noticed this year we had a
number of bills dealing with the
relationships of the boards and the oplc
and we decided that since the op has
become larger and larger
that that's something we ought to keep
thank you
are there any other questions comments
concerns
i would state that if
the committee chooses
we could
change line 12 just delete line 12 and
leave
november of 2022 as the
i believe we could make that change
without a major um
okay
thank you are there any other
questions for representative schuett
representative psychic
is there a second amendment
for the boxing and wrestling
there is a second amendment which
basically mirrors 14 24
with the exception it deletes the boxing
and wrestling commission
which we sort of took a straw poll
before if you'll recall that
this committee agreed that that should
not be regulated by oplc
that's the only change and that's the
one that will will be presented at the
executive session
with
it's we will only see one amendment at
the executive session yes okay all right
that's all i we don't usually have two
inventions
it's simpler if we don't yes
any other questions
all right thank you representative
schuett uh rep
director li cartney wishes just to speak
thank you madam chair for the record
lindsey courtney executive director oplc
uh oplc certainly doesn't take a
position um
on this bill
or on this amendment rather
and for the record i'm looking at one
four two four
um we
you know being at oplc the last couple
years it's been a little bit like
building an airplane while flying um
so i certainly you know would welcome
the input and i think the members of the
committee who would serve on this would
certainly i think find it
enlightening as to how
occupational licensing
is currently working in new hampshire
my only question or observation is
really
is
whether or not the scope of the
committee's work is sufficiently broad
i know that the committee throughout the
legislative session heard probably some
grumblings and complaints from
stakeholders
we've been strategic in trying not to
complain uh you know
regarding boards we have a good
relationship with the majority of them
but uh
for example should oplc be able to bring
issues to the to this oversight
committee regarding boards
um
true story
you know if a board is uh facilitating
the commission of a crime
and declines to do anything when that's
brought to their attention
is that something that we should be able
to bring to the to this oversight
committee's attention
as it's currently drafted it just says
the committee shall provide legislative
oversight and informational meetings on
the policies and rules of the office
i guess my suggestion would be to make
it clear that if
that if oplc observes
concerns
that we'd be able to bring that to the
oversight committee's attention but
certainly um we don't take a position on
this and you know if assume this passes
we look forward to working with the
committee
thank you i'd be happy to answer any
questions
thank you uh i would hope that if there
is a crime being committed you're
reporting it to the appropriate
authorities
um i did
thank you
representative schmidt has a question
oh that was going to be my suggestion i
thought we already had an attorney
general's office to handle that kind of
thing
yes whether or not
people exercise their discretion to
prosecute cases is a separate matter you
know but i think it from a structural
standpoint
there are you know by and large our
board members have very good intentions
i think the problem with the offices
have always been um and with the boards
that there's a lack of internal controls
um there's a comp you know there has
been um a lack of an inventory over what
the statutory regulatory requirements
are
um
the boards and the office historically
have just regulated based on how they've
always regulated without regard to what
the statute actually requires which is
why it's part of our plan to establish
internal controls but so i think that's
why we've gotten into a situation where
we stumble upon issues like this
and even with best intentions you know
there are a decent number of
legal issues out there that i would
think would be appropriate to bring to
follow-up
so
i i i do understand that there's a
difference between things which are
illegal and things which are crimes uh
and and certainly that's one of the
advantages of this commit news oversight
committee is to try to sort some of this
out because otherwise you're just doing
too much
uh all by yourself and without enough
thank you thank you are there any other
questions
representative
bailey do i understand it say that you'd
like it to flow both ways it's not just
us overseeing you you would like to be
able to have us oversee these boards if
you get into trouble with them
correct because
correct representative because i mean
i know that um the boards i shouldn't
say all of them but several of them may
feel differently but if you actually
look at oplc's authority it's it's quite
limited and if you look at the board's
authority it's generally not limited
they have uh
you know oftentimes full discretion uh
to regulate um what happens in their
profession
um
so i you know there are there are thing
i think that that uh that it should go
both ways um i think that for the most
part you know we've got 54 boards we've
got a good relationship with about 40 of
them uh 15 of them you've probably heard
from
um
but
but i think that there could be
improvements on both sides
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on this amendment to senate bill
330.
okay not seeing anyone
close the public hearing will resume at
three
did she know of any other boards that
did this
uh she's not saying
oh she said yes there's there's a few of
the very old board
that are
um that have that author and he's gonna
okay
i wonder if it's ever been used
well
oh
you won't be offended yeah well
one or the other nice to hear how mike's
doing yeah that would be nice i hope
oh yeah right right i have found
by the way that there are other boards
that can do the
what i have just done
she said
not most hold on some of the old boards
that doesn't mean that i'm
that i like this the fact that there's a
i would i voted again
thanks
yes information for uh everyone the
building closes at five and if anybody
feels the need to stay longer than five
yeah
all right
okay it's three o'clock i'm opening the
hearing on senate bill 333 and i call
senator avard
thank you madam chair and committee
members for the record i'm senator kevin
avart i represent district 12.
three wards of nashua one two and five
hollis brookline mason ridge new
upswitch and greenville
and i am the the prime sponsor of senate
bill 333
with regards to case management
and uh is there an echo in the room
there we go this is a little better
case management agencies have been
licensed in new hampshire for 28 years
by the bureau of health uh health
facilities as home care providers under
rsa 151 2
b
since the initial passage of hep
819 through gel car
on may 27 1993 the license of these
agencies is critical to ensuring the
health and welfare of citizens that they
serve
the enabling
statute was originally rsa 151 2b which
will
which this bill seeks to amend
and is appropriate place for the
language before you
the original license issued under hep
18 stated that home care provider
quote
case management there was no legislative
actions which directed the department to
alter this
during the course of rule revision
through jail car
the enabling statutory authority was
erroneously changed to rsa 151
to
ff
adult day care services
the case management agencies do not
provide adult day care services and
federal regulation prohibits them from
doing so
the department amended amendment is
problematic as it has unintended
consequences and the department
amendment creates a substant a
substantive change from the practices of
the last 28 years without explanation as
to why this monumental change
is being requested
excuse me senator what department
amendment are you talking about there's
a there's an amendment from the from the
department so that that'll be coming i'm
pretty sure or
so
um thank you yeah it should be noted
that uh three of the uh three of the
four from 1915
uh community-based care waivers
dd ihs and abd are under the plan of
correction for providing case management
services which are not in compliance
with federal law which requires that the
case management be provided
in a manner in which is free from
conflict of interest
the part the department amendment has
unintended consequences of limiting
solutions before
a plan
is in place to resolve the deficiencies
by cms
the independent case management agencies
have been providing services under home
care statute
for 28 years
they serve individuals in the community
and individuals wishing to transition
back into the community under medicaid
private insurance and private pay
there are significant significant cost
savings which results from keeping our
citizens out of nursing homes
i urge you to support my bill and there
are some folks here that will
talk more specifically if i could have
directed at them
um i just want to point out
in real life
real life case i was called by a
constituent
this weekend
and i i could put it on speaker
because she left me a voice message
senator my name is such and such
i'm a quadriplegic
i can't find somebody to get me in and
out of bed
i need help
i called uh
some people that were in the room to
help out with this with this particular
in case
uh there are people that that she said i
can't find somebody
um
and i immediately went to caroline
virtue
who who
will be speaking about this bill
to help provide this individual
with help um
i think that if if we re
if this doesn't pass the people that
have been serving the community and that
advocate
for those in such circumstances
if they're not around
i i don't know how you would help
somebody like this
so anyway um
i would i would ask you and beg you to
ask any technical questions for those
that are here to testify in support of
this bill it's been a very long day and
i really appreciate it and i hope that
you do pass this bill and i thank you
thank you i'm trying to
do i understand you correctly to say
that this operation has been proceeding
until hhs changed their rules
and now
the
the case management
businesses
do not comply with the rules
and therefore they'd be going out of
business that is my understanding
as i'm trying to convey to you yes
thank you i wish you testified for me
instead
thank you madam chair all right thank
you are there other questions for the
senator
okay
thank you very much
if anyone if i see you have written
testimony if you could pass it out and
if anyone else also has written
testimony pass it out at the same time
please
madam chair
my written testimony is with jeb curl up
and heidi kroll so may they please go
first
we'll do them first
good afternoon madam chair and members
of the committee um for the record my
name is heidi kroll i work at gallagher
callahan and gartrell and i'm here today
on behalf of life coping which is a
case management agency based in nashua
with a statewide footprint and i just we
are in support of sb 333 as amended by
the senate um and i wanted to just
briefly before i start discussing the
bill um
allow
jeb curl up who's the principal of life
coping to just briefly explain
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee for this opportunity to speak
uh my name is jeb curlop i'm with life
coping case management we're as a case
management agency located in nashville
we provide case management
throughout the state of new hampshire
life coping is an independent
licensed
conflict-free case management agency
which means we only provide case
management services to our clients
we do not provide any direct services to
them
rather we conduct a comprehensive needs
assessment of the patient's clinical and
non-medic non-clinical needs develop a
care plan and help find the appropriate
service providers
the case management we provide is a
health care service specifically home
and community-based care for the elderly
and chronically ill who are eligible for
a nursing home level of care so these
individuals would be in a nursing home
otherwise
case management agencies have many
nurses and social workers on staff who
regularly assess their clients medical
and non-medical needs and coordinate
their care so that they can safely live
at home
life coping serves clients who are
eligible for services under medicaid
waiver programs specifically choices for
independence
developmental disabilities acquired
so sb 333
is really intended just to be a very
simple housekeeping bill
the issue is that
from our understanding hhs has recently
taken the position that their statutory
authority to license case management
agencies needs to be clarified um this
came as a surprise to us because hhs as
you've heard from senator avart has been
licensing live coping and similar case
management agencies for nearly 30 years
pursuant to rsa 151
colon to b
as well as hhs rules
to carry that out sp 333 is simply meant
to clarify the department's authority to
continue licensing case management
agencies and really essentially maintain
the status quo
life coping fully supports licensing of
case management agencies
from our perspective it ensures critical
consumer protections and quality of care
for vulnerable populations that the case
management agencies serve
again those are elderly and disabled who
would otherwise
who are eligible for a nursing home
level of care
but
are able to stay in their homes and in
their communities
licensure also ensures that case
management agencies are held to the same
high standards that are applied to other
health care providers
and it protects new hampshire's federal
matching funds
it also allows a certain case man
certain case management agencies to be
eligible for critical federal funds
federal grants um so we would like to
explain uh from our perspective where we
stand with the law um and the rules
so rsa 151 is the residential care and
health facility licensing statute
the phrase case management agencies is
only explicitly mentioned
in rsa 151 colon 5 which is the section
where license fees are listed
the phrase case management agencies is
not explicitly listed by name in the
list of entities that appear under
rsa 151 colon 2 which is the section
about license or registration required
however
case management agencies are implicitly
listed there specifically under rsa 151
colon 2
roman 1 parentheses b
which refers to
quote home health care providers as
defined in the later part of the statute
151 colon
2 dash b
and when you go and read that definition
in rsa 151 colon 2 dash b it reads and i
quote
home healthcare provider means any
organization business entity or
subdivision thereof whether public or
private whether operated for profit or
not which is engaged in arranging
arranging or providing directly or
through contract arrangement one or more
of the following and then there is a
list of services that
clients patients could be eligible for
so case management agencies like life
coping are a business entity which is
engaged in arranging one or more of the
listed services that their clients need
case management agencies have and should
continue to fall within the definition
of home health care provider and the
licensing authority
there
and in fact
at one point life's coping's licensing
application actually referenced home
um
and you heard earlier senator avard
refer to
the rule it's our understanding that
hep 819
which is relative to case management
agencies used to reference
151 colon 2-b and however at some point
along the way the rule was changed an
error was made and it now
states that a license to operate a case
management agency is pursuant to 151
colon 2 roman 1f which is a reference to
adult daycare services and that's
clearly wrong we don't know why
you may hear that case management
agencies have not been licensed or
should not be licensed under home health
the home health care provider statute
and we would like to share three items
with you that demonstrate that case
management agencies have been licensed
under the home health care statute and
should continue to be
licensed under the home health care
statute
which again this simple fix is simply
meant to clarify
and one of the handouts i gave to you
first is that in
department rules he 805
it defines case management agency as an
agency that is licensed in accordance
with rsa 151 colon 2
roman 1 parentheses b and again that's
the law that says license is required
secondly another piece of evidence that
we have been
and should continue to be
licensed under home health care is that
in march of 2021 a report was issued by
the department of health and human
services about findings and
recommendations on new hampshire's
long-term supports and services for
seniors and individuals with physical
disabilities and the report reads and i
quote consider contracting with case
management entities directly rather than
having them licensed as home care
providers
through the standard medicaid provider
enrollment process so that is straight
from the department report
that we are
licensed as home care providers
and finally a third piece of evidence is
that case management agencies um
that they have been licensed under the
home health care statute is in hep
819 those rules say that licensed case
management agencies must comply with the
home care clients bill of rights which
is set forth in 151
colon 21b
and when you read that statute it says
that these client rights apply
only to services delivered by or on
behalf of a home health care provider
so this is yet further evidence that
case management agencies are licensed
under the home health care provider
statute
so in summary sb 333 as amended by the
senate simply adds case management
agencies explicitly to the definition of
home health care providers in order to
clarify that hhs does indeed have the
statutory authority to license case
management agencies
under this under that statute
this in our opinion will preserve the
status quo with respect to licensing of
case management agencies
that serve individuals covered by
medicaid as well as by private insurance
and private
self-pay patients
we thank you for your time and your
consideration and we respectfully ask
for your support of sb 333 as amended by
the senate
thank you are there any questions from
uh thank you i'm i'm hope hoping
i'm not getting the part about why the
case manager
i don't understand the distinction
between case management service provider
and case management agency and i also
don't understand why
there's an amendment to add case
management
in that existing paragraph that begins
with home health care's
providers and why it's why case
management doesn't have its own little
paragraph
right so i think um the case management
services provider and case management
agencies is probably one in the same i
think it's
i think it is one in the same um and to
answer your second question
we that's where we have been
that's the in our opinion that's where
the authority has come from
to license case management service
providers or case management agencies it
has come from this authority
um to license home health care providers
and
that's the
this information that i was just going
through
where
there are a variety of pieces of
kind of supporting supporting that and
in fact
from our perspective
we you know life coping is a
business entity
a private business entity
which is engaged in arranging
uh through contract arrangement one or
more of the following services for our
clients so that
language we think that that's been there
that that's where we think
the authority comes from but the
department is saying that it's
not clear and so we are simply proposing
to add including case management
thank you we appreciate your your
concern for clear clarity
uh any other questions
i'll yield to you first but i'm sure
okay yeah mike my concern is
uh the
h e
h e e 805 rules
are five years old at this point but and
the 819 rules are not yet online
and i'm wondering where uh
are they are they when were they passed
um
my understanding is that the h19 rules
okay
well
so they are they're not new okay i don't
know they're so mike my concern then is
what's happening now that causes
that that causes the need for this why
if the
one set of rules is
five years old and another one is nine
years old
that's a great question madam chair so
we had a
piece of legislation last
last year
which ultimately
a provision went into sb 162
which
initially started out as a
discussion discussion
supposed to be a discussion about
talking about homeless shelter case
management
um ultimately when it got put into sp
162 it was
kind of watered down and talked more
just about
talking about licensing of case
management and the department under that
law was supposed to hold some
stakeholder meetings
and we actually only had one that was
held in the fall the early fall with the
department and it was at on that zoom
call that we learned that the department
felt like they were lacking
statutory authority to license case
management agencies and as i said
when i began my testimony that was quite
a surprise to us because
we have been licensed for
approximately 28 years
and
these rules are not new rules
okay
and
all right so oh actually if it's if it
was from 2013
i mean that would imply that it's it's
over nine years old and it's about to
expire next year so that's why it would
be
coming up for a revision
okay
thank you for clearing that up
i think that this was my my question was
where does this kind of like hear a ball
start and it seems to me that
it was with sb 162
and an amendment that was
not really
targeted that ended up not saying what
it wanted to be and then therefore
confused homeless shelter
with case management is that what you're
saying
initially in there was um
there
i think it initially started out as
sb-140 but then ultimately the language
was put into one sb 162 and there was
discussion about
the department getting funding for case
management with respect to homeless
shelters and the phrase case management
kind of caught our attention given the
business
and
but ultimately when and so that i think
initially at least our understanding was
there was supposed to be a discussion
around case management in the context of
homeless shelters but ultimately when it
went into sb-162 it was
to have a discussion just about case
management licensing and that's when we
had
like i said a zoom call in early fall
with the department and other
stakeholders and that's when we first
concern
about feeling like they didn't have the
thank you
interesting any other questions
thank you madam chair
so this is a little bit of a
handful here to to grasp all this
because it's a little bit about
what just what you see is not what you
get
anyway so um
has there been any further action
involving
no there i there's not there's nothing i
mean the the case there is no court
issues okay that that's the answer is no
um
so
and
this homeless shelter thing it sounds
like that was kind of appended on to
uh the the existing business that you've
been doing for a long long time
the homeless shelter issue i think kind
of got resolved
through other legislation so the
department removed reference to case
management around
um homeless shelter and they got the um
the allocation of money that they were
looking for and so
that went away that went away yes that
went away okay so we don't have to worry
about homeless shelters anymore correct
in context of this bill
follow-up follow-up okay so
um
and
have you done any exploration with the
with the feds because presumably if the
agency if the department is saying we
don't know that we have the authority to
be doing this at all or adequate
authority or whatever
then i would think that there would have
been some inquiries with the feds to
find out whether that was the case
whether you were on sal you guys were on
solid ground
uh or whether this was 28
28 years of
being done this way and it never should
have been done that way
because that's kind of sounds to me like
that's where
uh the the department is they're kind of
saying we don't think we have the
authority to do this
well i think the licensing is a critical
piece you can hear me okay um i think
the licensing is a critical piece um
for a variety of reasons including
the state of new hampshire getting
federal matching funds
as well as as i mentioned in my
testimony
some of the case management agencies
with their licensing that allow that's a
criteria in order for them to be
eligible for federal grant money
so um
[Music]
um
i think i don't think there's any
question about the
um the need and the authority for
licensing
it's just that the department is looking
at at rsa 151 and not seeing
explicit authority to license case
management agencies and that was news to
us because as i
the paragraph i read to you it we've we
do feel like we
qualify as a business entity
which is engaged in arranging
through contract arrangement one of more
of the following services for the
clients we serve and we have been
licensed under that
statute
for approximately 28 years so we were
surprised to hear of the department's
concern but we think this this is really
purely meant to be a housekeeping item
with respect to just inserting
explicitly
the phrase including a case management
services provider to just make it
okay so i'll
stop asking questions for the moment and
let some of my colleagues continue
representative larkis
thank you um
so have you had uh consulted with the
department and uh you know
with if we added this language would
they feel comfortable that they have the
authority to provide the licensing
you're looking for
um the department is um
i think wants to put their the authority
in a
different section of rsa 151
and our concern with that is that
um i think
we're concerned that it would have
unintended consequences given that we
have been licensed under
um
colon 2
dash b
[Music]
as an example
we
[Music]
pull it up here
um the third example i gave before about
the case management agencies are
required to
be compliant with home care clients bill
of rights as an example the licensing
rules require that but when you go back
to the law you see that though that
provision about compliance with home
care clients bill of rights
only applies to services delivered
on our behalf
by or on behalf of the home health care
provider and there are i think other
things
along those lines that we're concerned
if we put the statutory authority
in a different place
we would have unintended consequences
follow-up
okay but they may prefer it somewhere
else you may disagree that's fine but
the question is if
this bill were passed
do you have any assurance from hhs that
they would be convinced that they have
the authority to provide the licensing
you want i do believe that it would
clearly give them the authority yes but
you follow up i mean you don't have that
clearly from them
is that true
i don't have that from them okay thank
you
okay
other questions
representative fellows
thank you madam chair um i
i didn't catch
what do you work for for a
health care management provider i work
at gallagher callahan and gartrell i'm a
foreign yes
and this is jeb curl up and he's the
what is your organization
of life coping what is your organization
organization is uh life coping or a case
management agency um
we provide case management throughout
the state of new hampshire and have been
for the last
30 years
um
this program that we work on that were
for the licensing none of this is um
this isn't um really alien to the
federal government these programs exist
virtually through every of the 50 states
in our country the purpose is to help
individuals to
remain safely and independently at home
with services and out of institutions so
this would be for nursing homes
where you'd be keeping people at seventy
to seventy five thousand dollars a year
with our program we'll keep them in the
community for fifteen to twenty thousand
dollars a year so you take that fifty
five thousand dollar savings multiply
that by four thousand people and you've
got several hundred million dollars a
year that you're saving
um this our agency's been licensed um
for
since uh
the um well the case management agencies
have been licensed for the last 28 years
we've got a copy of the license here
and um
as far as
the federal
um approval or authorization or
authority or
this is these programs are going on
throughout the united states every state
has a program like this
we came into this issue with with the
department
when there was a
rfp for
case management and homeless shelters
and then there was question about who
would be providing the case management
in the homeless shelters and then out of
that grew
where we are today
with the department saying that they
don't
or may not have statutory authority to
licensed case management agencies so
we're saying that basically they have
been licensing us for the last 28 years
um i've got our license right here we
have the language that's in
in the rsa as that refers to us under
the home health care providers and it
basically these are people who would be
in nursing homes or they may previously
they would have been in the laconia
school
which was shut down
years ago but it's helping these people
to remain safely uh in the community for
with well as far as cfi with great
savings the state so
it's not an alien or you know really uh
unusual program these are going on
throughout the united states
thank you
well i
am not a lawyer and i don't play one on
tv either but i have some familiarity
with a legal concept called latches
which says that if you've been doing
something for a long long long long time
you can't suddenly be deprived of the
right to continue to do that
without
a
very good cause
so
is that some aspect that you've explored
especially
uh we have not um no i mean i think
i think there's consensus that we should
i hope there's consensus that we should
continue to be licensed as we have been
it's just cl literally a house in from
our perspective a housekeeping item to
just be very explicit in the law rather
than having to read the words that i
read to you earlier where you kind of
have to piece together
out of that out of that paragraph
how we fall into it
and i just did want to mention there was
reference to the license and that is
included in the testimony that we handed
in to the committee
thank you thank you questions represent
fellows
um thank you madam chair i i i didn't
actually even get to my question
so my question was i was trying to find
out you know so you are um a case you do
case case management services
do you also provide home health care
services you know such as sending an aid
to the home and
or do you do you only
refer to
other places for the actual service
provision
excellent question um we are a a
conflict-free case management agency
which means that we
provide exclusively case management
services
and we do not provide any direct
services so i'm not deciding what
services your mother may need and then
providing those services and
that's something that the federal
government and actually the state of new
hampshire is in on the process of a
corrective action plan for conflict-free
case management um and that that's of
really um actually um a very good point
in terms of what might be just totally a
a consequence of uh
what
not licensing case management would do
and basically the state is being
assisted now with its
conflict-free case management plan as a
result of having i think new hampshire's
uh we're a unique state and that we do
have independent case management
agencies and many states don't and many
states are are
are struggling with this whole concept
of the conflict that you alluded to so
yeah thank you that's an excellent
question i hope i've
answered it
other questions
ms kroll would be fair to say that
the
819 rules on
case management are expiring in january
is
is the
department's
is departments concerned part of their
or do you know anything about these i i
don't want to speak for them madam chair
okay fair enough i shouldn't have asked
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
uh thank you madam chair
and committee members
uh my name is alex kutrubis i'm here on
behalf of my client
the community support network which is
the association of the ten area agencies
that provide services and supports to
individuals with developmental
disabilities and acquired brain
disorders
we did not take a position on this
legislation in the senate however we are
here with some concerns about it and
really the reason is as introduced the
bill just added
five words including a case management
agency to the definition of health care
home health care provider under rsa 151
which is as you heard the residential
care and health facility licensing
statute that's administered by dhhs
several weeks after the public hearing
in the senate there was a replace all
amendment
that we believe has altered the scope
and reach of the legislation
in general we believe that this bill as
amended by the senate is ambiguous and
confusing for example the language on
line six
adds case management to the definition
of home health care provider
this action would lump case management
with a long list of direct service
providers that are on lines 8 through
11.
yet if you go down to line 22
kate it says case management activities
shall not include activities which
constitute the direct delivery of other
services so why are we amending
a direct service definition to include
case management
at the bill's public hearing in the
senate hhs offered an amendment
to solve at least one of the stated
goals of this legislation but again the
bill as amended by the senate is not
what was proposed by the department
and obviously this is concerning because
hhs is going to be the state agency that
will administer and enforce this law
the suggested language
and history of this issue was contained
in a letter that was sent to speaker
packard dated november 18 2021
it's also unclear to us
if the purpose of this bill is to merely
license the entities that have
historically been licensed or is it to
expand licensure to new entities and
again if you look at the letter that was
sent to the speaker of the house
we don't have that letter
uh well it's not my it's a letter from
hhs um so i don't want to speak for them
or present their letter but i'm happy to
get you a copy of it but in that letter
there's concern that mental health
housing children services developmental
disabilities could be pulled into
requiring a license for case management
if we don't amend this statute correctly
we're also confused about the general
purpose of this bill
there were inconsistent reasons provided
for why this bill is here uh there were
inconsistent reasons i think provided
today
uh for example you heard it was an
administrative fix it's a it's a
housekeeping bill
but the sponsor said today
we talked about conflict of interest and
how some of the medicaid waivers are out
of compliance
is it a bill to
get us into compliance with conflict of
interest or is it just to license the
people that have been licensed for 28
years i think there's there's a lot of
different statements that have been made
and
i i think we need to get some
clarification on that before we pass the
bill
if it's an attempt
to try and enforce the conflict-free
case management issue
we see some problems with how it's
worded in the bill as presented here
as you heard conflict-free case
management requires that the assessment
and coordination of service is separate
from the delivery of service and the
goal is to limit any conscious or
unconscious bias that a case manager or
case management agency may have
hhs is currently working with all of the
stakeholders to get new hampshire into
compliance they're working with with cms
centers for medicare and medicaid
services they're working with the air
agencies they're working with the
independent case management companies
we already have a plan in place
it's a corrective action plan as you
heard
and the goal is to be in compliance by
august of 2023
it's also important to note that adding
again to the confusion of this issue
the words case management or case
management service provider do not
appear in rsa 171 which is the law that
governs developmental disabilities
case management also does not appear in
the administrative rules h.e.m 500 that
clarify 171a which again is the dd
statute
dd uses the term service coordination
and again because of these issues i
think hhs amendment is the is the way to
go we shouldn't be trying to regulate
a human service system that's governed
under 171a under 151. it doesn't make
any sense to do that and you heard about
conflict of interest i think this bill
as presented by the senate has a lot of
conflicts have been or excuse me
unintended consequences and again it
goes back to the issue of conflict of
interest there are exceptions
under the federal law for conflict of
if you can demonstrate that the only
willing and qualified case manager for
the individual who needs the service is
also affiliated with the direct service
provider you can have an exception if
there's a lack of service providers and
obviously we have a health care
workforce shortage in the state right
now and we don't want to put something
that's overly broad in the statute
that could
deny people's services
but again we are working to get in
compliance with the with the conflict of
free conflict free case management issue
but we have to do it in a thoughtful way
over time
phase individuals in
the system as it's configured
the developmental disability system as
it's currently configured has been in
place for a long long time
and it's going to take some time to
unwind that which is why we need to take
our time and make sure that we do it
correctly so again
if we need to amend the statute or amend
the rule to come into compliance with
federal law
dhhs knows how to do that they're not
shy as you know about coming to the
legislature and asking for changes they
are not asking for this
so i think we need to be very cautious
about amending it if they're if they're
not in agreement and do not feel that it
gives them the correct language and the
correct authority to do what they need
to do whether it's conflict of interest
or whether it's to license the existing
case management companies if the goal of
this and the purpose of this is just to
license the independent case managers as
has been the case for many years we have
no problem with it but we think it goes
beyond that at this point
so thank you madam chair
thank you i believe
is there a question to representative
road thank you madam chairman um
throughout your testimony you you you
repeatedly um use the the terminology we
are
working to fix this or we are working
towards um addressing you know becoming
in compliance can you just be very
specific on who is we
well it's a broad group of stakeholders
that there's
a variety of work groups that dhhs has
formulated around the conflict uh free
case management issue so anyone is
welcome to to join those groups but it's
really being spearheaded by dhhs
but anyone who's a stakeholder is uh is
part of those groups at one way one way
thank you
so there was a question asked by
representative to um
to the people that testified prior to
you about dhhs and
if i'm not mistaken it was
you know being on board with this and if
i'm not mistaken they had said that they
believed that they were are you are you
saying that dhhs is not
they i mean i don't want to speak for
the department but they're not on board
with this they provided a letter okay
they provided a letter in the senate
that
suggested language to solve this issue
that is not what is before you as
amended by the senate it's a completely
different
thank you apologize
any other questions
i have one representative bailey
thank you didn't we hear earlier that
dhs doesn't really want anything to do
with this
i i i don't want to speak for the
department but i believe that they want
to continue to license case management
agencies
we need to let them speak for themselves
so please don't ask any questions about
what dhs intends
um
but i would ask you if your concern
is that this
legislation appears to muddle the case
management of the
home and community-based care
organizations which these people are
talking with the developmentally
disabled
case management which is
i would assume it would be fairly
similar in what you do
but it's driven by different statutes is
that correct
yes i mean case management the case
management functions are very similar
but it's a different system it's
configured differently and historically
the dd system case management has been a
part of
the delivery of the service and again
we're trying to unwind that
slowly
uh over time in consultation with okay
cms and all the stakeholders
so yes we need to amend the correct
statute and so that in your case the
development of disabled case management
conflict-free case management issue may
have arisen because you did have
conflicts yeah correct there is no
conflict with the cfi case management
but there but there is there is still
but we're working to change it there is
conflict with the dd case management
which is why we're under the corrective
action plan
thank you that makes things a little
clearer thank you are there any other
questions
representative fellows can i just get
you to repeat those last two sentences
without acronyms so i know what so
there's four we have four waivers
medicaid waivers in the state of new
hampshire home and community-based
waivers they uh three of them are
considered developmental services
waivers
one is the dd waiver developmental
disabilities waiver which is for adults
who have developmental disabilities one
is called the in-home support waiver
which is for children under the age of
21 who have severe disabilities
and we have the acquired brain disorder
waiver which is people who have uh
over the age of 21 who have have a brain
injury we need services and supports
those three waivers are under a
corrective action plan with the federal
government
and i think this bill is attempting to
put pressure on
new hampshire to get into compliance
with that
but that's not what i wanted to
speculate on what what what that's what
the sponsors are there he said that this
could be used as a tool to enforce that
law
thank you are there any other questions
president schmidt
i i think you're the chair's
earlier remark about hearing from the
department is
appropriate at this time so we don't
speculate about what the department says
you're welcome
uh you said you said you had written
testimony
uh so yes good afternoon for the record
my name is melissa sainz here i'm the
chief lead officer for the department of
health and human services and i oversee
the office the bureau of licensing and
certification
i don't have any written testimony i
have a proposed amendment which amends
the current language that was passed out
of the senate i'm happy to distribute
first explain to us why we need why
what your intentions are because that
appears to be the subject of immigration
sure speculation absolutely happy to do
so
so um
uh heidi kroll was correct we did
convene a stakeholder group we were
asked to do so by the legislature to
review
case management and the licensure of
case management and come up with a plan
while we were doing under
who in the legislature asked you and
what it was senate bill
162. senate bill 162. thank you
thank you um and so
uh we began reviewing that at the same
time we were amending our rules for uh
hep 819 which overs which is the uh
oversight authority for um for case
management agencies under rsa 151 and so
while we were doing that um
the the statutory authority that is
listed currently on on the rules right
now is rsa 151.5
and that is the only place in rsa151
where the term case management agency
exists and that is the fees section so
it essentially says that people need to
be charged a certain fee if they want to
be a case management agency
but that's typically not what we would
see in a statutory authority to create
rules
for for that licensure
so in
an effort to
clarify and ensure that case management
agencies can continue to be licensed and
that there is that appropriate statutory
authority when we go in front of jailcar
we have suggested that we license
continued obviously to license case
management agencies but what we did was
we pulled out the existing language that
was in the rules
that has been approved by jail car for
for a
period of time now as well as those who
are exempt
from licensure as a case management
agency one of those being the area
agencies and those currently exist in
the rules right now so we verbatim took
them from the rules and placed them in a
a paragraph and presented that to
senator bradley and then senator bradley
was working and knew that senator evard
was working with this group here and so
he had asked that that we utilized this
vehicle
and instead of
a one that senator brownlee had to move
this language forward so
essentially
when it went in front of the senate the
language changed to something that was
proposed by by um by heidi kroll and and
the group um that is our their case
management agencies and so we then took
that language in an effort to
collaborate and and amended some of it
so that it would be
relevant to licensure
so that we are proposing are say that it
be rsa 151 2 instead of rsa 151 2b
and the reason for that is that it it is
not considered from a light a state
licensure perspective they are not
considered home healthy home health
agencies
they have always been separate if
somebody if a case management agency
also has
a home health component to it they're
required to be duly licensed so they
have to hold two separate licenses so
case management agencies from a
licensing perspective are not considered
home health agencies and so we suggest
instead of putting in section 2b to put
it in the general section which
outlines all of the other entities that
need to be um that needs to be licensed
hospitals nursing homes adult day care
centers and all those others so it would
just be its own section so we took their
language and
amended that put it instead of keeping
it in 2b uh we're requesting to put it
in section two
and then we also removed a lot of the
language that was not typically things
that you would see in a licensing
statute such as the conflict-free case
management that's something that's a
federal requirement this is state
licensing law this is really about the
licensure of case management's here case
management agencies here in new
hampshire
and although there may be some
requirements under the waiver and all
that those are very separate and
distinct and not actually
part of all any of our statutes when it
comes to
when it comes to licensing for example
hospitals hospitals are currently
licensed there's many many many federal
requirements that hospitals are required
to comply with
but we don't put all of those
requirements in the licensing statute
the licensing statute is just there
specifically to say the state needs to
license these entities and it's for the
health and safety of the patients that
are being seen or the clients that are
being seen by those entities and so that
is our suggestion so we are we are
comfortable with the with the definition
language that they have we just remove
some of the areas in which it may be
something that's in a federal law in a
waiver or somewhere um and that is
essentially typically something you
would see in rules and so that's that's
what this this amendment is for i know
there's a lot of things that came that
have come up a lot of questions i'm
happy to go through and answer some of
those questions
i don't know if anyone wants to if you
want me to pause now and see or if you
want me to go through and answer some of
those questions
thank you for coming before us
did you did you present what you just
presented us to the senate so so there
was a present presentation i did not
present it there were other members who
presented it and i don't know if they
got into this uh great of detail the
amendment uh the language that we had
proposed and the amended language that
came the day of the senate hearing the
public hearing i wasn't physically
present but they were different and so
that was i don't i'm not a hundred
percent sure what the testimony was but
wasn't that nice they're letting us weed
out the details
representative
um
who's doing the licensing here
the bureau of licensing
excuse me does the hhs have its own
area of licensing yes sir then why is
this bill here
this is a headache because it's in
statute
a lot of the requirements for licenses
are in statute they can't just make up
and why is it here it's because we're
stuck with it
the
i will say that it is extremely
unfortunate
that this is showing up today because
our deadline is next week
i would appreciate having a copies of
your amendment and then i think we will
let people ask questions absolutely you
want me to hand that now
yeah
and who are there questions please
okay well i i do kind of have a question
of course
so
you are of course working to revise your
819 rule which is expiring in january
right okay
and you have no problem with continuing
the licensure you correct just a
a can't a disagreement
on the policeman where it should be
placed okay fine that's
and the
um conflict-free case management is not
in the
home and community-based care it's in
the other areas of
medicaid case management dd and correct
okay well that's
uh does anyone else have any questions
or clarifying well we have all these
experts here
brooks and laccas
so first um i understand you have this
amendment you've got some concerns about
the
current senate bill but i guess my
question is if the senate bill were
passed as it stands right now
um first of all
you know do you think you'd have the
authority to license
these case management organizations
number one
and number two
what problems do you think would be
caused with the current language
so um as for the placement of it that
the case management agencies are are
included in the home health um statute
there's a lot of
requirements under home health that
don't exist for case management case
management as
as spoken by alex earlier there is a
their home healthcare is a direct care
service and in case management is
indirect and if we
they currently have to be licensed duly
licensed if they perform both services
and the oversight of a home health
agency is very different
in that
we we actually oversee the services that
are being provided we conduct surveys
very differently at a home health
provider
and we review medical records and other
things differently than if it were a
case management agency
and um also the um
the home health i've spoken with gina
balkas here and she's she's here from
the home health association they haven't
been considered
a case management agencies have not been
considered a home health from their
perspective but
the certification as well for
medicare because it's the bureau of
licensing and certification
many of our home health agencies are
certified
as well as licensed and there's a
what it's called is a deemed licensure
so if they're compliant with cms
regulations
under certification they can receive a
state license
and so we typically have
very different sections for each of
those entities to be surveyed in in very
different ways because of the fact that
some of them are certified some of them
are not some of them only provide
personal care some of them provide a
whole host of hospice services so it's
it just it would make the department
change a lot of its practices and it may
have unintended consequences that we're
just not aware of yet
representative bailey thank you just
just a clarification earlier we heard
about
up at least some subset of this is
conflict-free whichever only means they
don't actually provide any services at
all they arrange for other people to
provide services
um
is that correct so the conflict-free
case management is something that's in
federal law that's required and is being
overseen by our long-term supports and
services that's not actually a licensing
function
and that's one of the requirements one
of the requests that we have is that
that be removed because it's not a state
law licensing issue it is a it's a more
of a federal government and compliance
issue with the with our cert current
waivers and other services that are
provided there and follow-up
at one point you mentioned there was a
conflict where they had to have dual
licenses that's if they at that point
they would not be conflict-free right
they're providing themselves they're
managing
so i i actually i have individuals here
who may be able to answer that question
but from a licensing perspective that's
not something that we we look at at all
because that conflict-free case
management issue is a federal and a
funding and a waiver issue
licensing really just looks at are you
doing the services are you doing it in a
safe way and to promote the health of
the individual if you're doing case
management you get one license if you're
doing home health you get one license or
if you're doing both then you need to
get two licenses you need to have a
license for each so that's where our
authority ends and and some of the other
you know medicaid compliance and all
that picks up and and so that's not
really a licensing function at all well
so one one more
can't you just give them their own
paragraph
yes yeah that's what we're suggesting is
that they get their own paragraph that
other comments representative fellows um
what are community settings is that
nursing homes is it anything else
community settings are are not in
nursing homes they're in out in the
community um at people's homes and other
settings that would not uh that would
in a in a like a nursing home or an
assisted living so they're not in a
actual
yes that's a healthcare facility
to provide these services outside of the
the saints here would be fair to say
that your statute is a mess
yes yeah and we actually have done so
many so much work on it to try to amend
rsa 151 because it's so large
i mean we have we have drafts and
nobody's ever really wanted to take it
up and we actually proposed it right
before kovid and somebody said oh no not
yet so um so i'm happy to engage with
anyone who is who is
in amending our statute that would be
wonderful
it would be very helpful
that's the impression i'm getting yes
yes thank you representative blackis um
this is actually i think rest of the
chair what i'm wondering is if the uh
home health care people or the the case
management sorry the case management
people are still here i wonder if they
have another person
in support of the bill who is a case
manager who is up next okay excellent
thank you
okay other questions
all right and thank you thank you so
much
thank you madam chair members of the
committee
um i'm sorry that you got a little more
than um you bargained for here today
um
i i just wanna say a couple of things
um the reason
we are before you with this bill
is due
to the lack of
ins there's no institutional memory
within the department anymore there has
been
a great deal
of
of change
and
i have held a license
as a health care provider
in the state of new hampshire for over
40 years home care licenses hospice
licenses case management
licenses
i was around when we did the inception
of the case management licensure and it
was
absolutely
done
under the statute that the bill as it
came up came over from the senate seeks
to amend
any claim to the contrary is patently
false
the other thing that i heard hear from
attorney saint cyr
is that
we are not surveyed by her staff
and that the medical our medical records
are not reviewed i have to apply for a
new license annually with the bureau of
health facilities
and surveyors from her department come
out
and
go through
the rules and regulations
and conduct a survey at my facility
which
is several hours long and that includes
the review
of medical records so it's facts
like these that
that are sliding into a mission is is
the problem
that we are
we seek to amend here
today changing this statute
from
our rsa 150
one sorry colon 2-b
has
unintended consequences not the least of
which
is that it removes protections that are
offered to the patients we serve
now
we've always
abided by those protections
if you wanna
trust us not to we're not the only ones
there are seven providers i'm gonna
treat people with respect and dignity
regardless of what the law says
and
i will point out that i i worked on
those statutes and the language that's
in there as
gina balkas from the home care
association
should be able
to
recall she was sitting
beside or in the same room a lot of this
time
the other thing that i will very
briefly
speak to
um
is
the
other four waivers and the plan of
correction
the plan of
cms first came down and said new
hampshire you can't provide case
management like this in 2016.
mr
um people testified here today
that um you know we have time and there
are all these groups working on it cms
is sick of this and we're out of time
and it ends in june of 2023
and i think we should be careful
although we are not attempting to
address
that problem with this legislation
i would ask that you be careful
bar any possible
solutions
thank you
thank you eddie are there any questions
representative black
so um
the question is
and it's not clear to me from what you
said are you supporting what's in the
senate bill as it exists today
uh would you support uh this amendment
uh 1635 h which was just uh
passed out
i'm trying to figure out
what we can do that will actually
help deal with the problem and it's not
clear
so i support
senate bill
333 as it was amended by the senate
the additional
language
that the department has a problem with
on the bottom
was added
[Music]
by the senate
it is
a language that appears in federal law
the senate chose not to include the
citation i'm not exactly
certain why um
but but that language must be followed
whether or not
um
it's it's in this bill
madam chair for the record my name is
robert clegg
the the language and paragraph two was
put in by the senate and they left out
the site because we know that most of
the time the legislature doesn't like to
say
the federal law because then to try to
change it requires a whole new set of
rules
so they added just the just the the
language
and as as
carolyn said it does say in that
has to be conflict-free
and the problem is is right now they're
under a plan of of correction because
there are agencies that are providing
both the case management
and the in the service
and so you send one person
to that location and you get the charge
for two people even though it's the same
person doing the same thing
so
that's illegal and i understand that if
they can get rid of case managers
then cms does say if there are no case
managers in your state
and you can't get a case manager then
the provider can be also the case
manager understand that a case manager
is the one that sits there and says
here's what we believe these people need
for services
those services are granted it's up to
the case manager at that point
to determine as on their visits whether
or not they're getting the services that
the state is being billed for
and over the years as i've been involved
i can tell you that many times they
aren't getting the services they're
being built for all right mike
follow up
yeah i'm more addressing not not
section two of the bill
but section one of the bill and the
question of whether there's that
language which puts it in 151 colon 2-b
or the proposed amendment which just
puts it in
151 colon 2 um section roman i 1.
um that if i could get an answer just to
that part just to that part the senate
was offered the same the same amendment
the senate rejected it it was a
different lawyer in in the senate
um that
it wasn't melissa but the senate
outright rejected it every senator said
no
and and i don't believe that if he
changed it back that the senate would
accept it in fact the senate has said
they won't this is the way they want it
to be done the arguments over there took
weeks they weren't just one hearing it
was weeks uh quick follow-up
hopefully quick um i mean do you at
least have uh
can you give summarize very briefly what
their concern was with the proposed
language by the department
every time the department came in they
felt that the department wasn't doing
what it should do
one as a part of a correction
if you're doing something that's not
legal and jeopardizes our ability to
collect money from cms
they want they want the correction to
start here and be correct
case managers need to be where they've
been and and to be to be licensed the
same way
there are a lot of things that if you
did the amendment that they're asking
for case managers would no longer be
able to provide services to private
clients
and so
there's a number of issues with that
amendment that's been hashed out in the
senate as i said weeks
yes thank you and they gave us uh
i agree
all right
any other comments
i'm i'm not entirely sure i even
understand this correctly but i'm
wondering if
the amendment that the little amendment
that we had
is
essentially the same words
that's
in in the senate bill if when we get
down to case management we just use the
first sentence in the last sentence and
not the stuff in the middle about
individuals
i don't think that's exactly
suitable for a public hearing at this
point it's
what
you're
you're wordsmithing and that's more
suitable for an executive solution
i'm just trying to understand if
that set of words works for them and
it's just them
i think that's they've already said that
the senate
they fought over this for weeks and
refused it so so i would say that that
means those words are not acceptable
okay and then in that case following
yes plea thank you
it's late i'm sorry
um
if we were not to pass this bill
the house were not to pass this bill
what would happen and would the issues
related to
the federal money
be addressed somehow
if the if the house were not to pass
this bill we believe things would be
remain the same as they are
we would still be licensed under the
under the home care and and we would
still be case managers and the state of
new hampshire would still have to comply
with the federal law that says
um it has to be conflict-free
yes
and we have had testimony that the
conflicts are primarily in the
the case managers licensed under
rsa 171 which is
and i don't know if that is true or if
or if that's even relevant
i i believe that they're unlicensed in
the other
systems is my understanding thank you
yeah
any other questions for miss virtue and
okay thank you very much for the
information
thank you very much for the opportunity
to appear here today i
sat on this committee
under
chairman bob mercer
and
i learned
so much
from
him and my experience and if you still
have the
brick wall award plaques on your wall do
you
thank you madam chairman and members of
the committee i'm gina balkas and i'm
the ceo of the granite state home health
and hospice association we represent
home care hospice and palliative care
providers and the people they serve
so like mr kotrubus when this bill was
introduced in the senate we were neutral
on the bill
because at the time the bill only had
section one which was simply adding
case management providers to the home
health statute and and and i would agree
that you know the word the fact that
they arrange services qualifies them to
be in that statute
um i think that our concern and the
reason that i'm here today is when i saw
the bill as passed by the senate with
the new definition i do believe the
definition is overly broad and very
confusing and um
feel that the link much of the language
that's in there about conflict-free case
management applies only to
um
federal waiver services
you may in fact have case management
service provider agencies out there that
are private only
and that do that do not do any
uh waiver services
so the definition should be
much clearer
um i feel that the department's
amendment that was presented today
achieves that i do believe that i saw
the amendment that was presented to the
senate it was different than what was
presented today because it included a
list of service providers who are
exempted i think the amendment you have
before you today is cleaner
uh and it just clarifies that agents you
know that home that
case management agencies would have
their own paragraph and own definition
uh i think that um i have read the home
health client bill of rights i think
that could easily still apply to case
management agencies it could be applied
in rural
or the statute could simply be amended
to add that case management agencies
should provide the home care client's
bill of rights
but you know there are other sections of
the law that apply including home care
discharge regulations and other things
like that so i just want to i i
was hoping not to have to jump into this
bill because it seems now that it's
begun it's gotten a little controversial
but i do feel the amount that the
definition that was added by the senate
is very confusing and will muddy the
waters for
for a range of health care providers
that may in fact provide case management
services under their existing licenses
and now we'll look at this and say oh do
i now need to be licensed separately
because we provide some of these
services so um i would ask that you give
serious consideration to the
department's amendment that they shared
today thank you
representative pierce thank you madam
chair did we not just hear that
under
part two basically line 15 on this
definition is a federal definition
so my understanding of the definition
is that the definition is is a federal
definition that applies only to
waive medicaid waiver services
not
services that might be applau provided
by other
case management agencies that don't have
anything to do with waiver services
so it would certainly be appropriate to
have those definitions in the the waiver
rules or the medicaid rules i don't
think it it should be in the def the
thank you
all right i know
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on senate bill 333
all right seeing none i'm going to close
the hearing
we will not be voting on any of these
bills today
and i would hope
that all members of the committee spend
their weekend readings rsa 151
and studying up on it there will be a
quiz
representative scitec i'd like to note
thank you we will celebrate
appropriately
um
you